So, wofür gehst du aus?
Hallo Puxtwitch
Alter Aliexpress
Ich will mich echt unbedingt auf die Login-Seite weiterleiten, was auch immer. Mal ein paar Tabs zu machen.
Ja, es geht weiter. Jetzt aus. Ich muss erst noch das Pepega-Board starten.
Und noch einen Twitch-Post machen. Äh, Twitter-Post. Warum heißt das auch so ähnlich?
Wobei man macht ja keinen Twitter-Post, man tweetet ja.
In zwei bis drei Stunden? Es könnte sein, da ich da noch on bin.
Diggy, das könnte noch sein.
Aber das wird knapp.
Alter, sag mal, haben die in diesem komischen Chill-Dings immer das gleiche laufen?
Ich hab extra jetzt schon weiter gedrückt als das letzte Mal.
Wupp wupp wupp.
Aja ja.
Starten wir den Krempel mal.
Pepega-Board muss gestartet werden.
Hast du schon immer so viel gestreamt? Nein.
Der heilige Bim-Bam ist auch da.
Mit Emoji-Support. Ja, allerdings gefaked.
Ich hab einfach einen Browser-Addon installiert, was Twitch-Emoji kann.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, ich hab's ausgetrickst.
Soll ich heute noch einen Twitter-Post machen?
So, Twitter-Post ist raus.
Ja ja, Zorgorn gibt es.
Ich hab sogar schon was gefunden.
Die offizielle Twitch-RP ist ein bisschen blöd zu verwenden, da brauchst du einen RP-Token und alles.
Aber es gibt freie Twitch-ARPs, die das für einen machen.
Guck da, Halbschatten, da taucht er auch.
So, die Frage haben wir beantwortet.
Das haben wir auch beantwortet.
Auch haben wir auch beantwortet vorhin.
Okay, keine offenen Fragen.
Bam, easy.
Also, was wir jetzt machen ist, wir machen zwei Sachen.
Erst einmal, ich verschiebe das mal kurz, einmal basteln wir heute ein bisschen Arduino ESP32 wieder.
Aber vorher kaufen wir in China ein.
Ich hab mich sogar eingeloggt bei AliExpress, ich muss jetzt gucken, dass ich nix liege.
Denn AliExpress lässt mich nicht mal suchen neuerdings, wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin und das liegt an Unity Media.
Oder ich könnte wetten, dass es an Unity Media liegt.
Dass zu viel aus diesem Unity Media Netz komische Dinger bei AliExpress machen und deswegen AliExpress das gesperrt hat.
Das ist auch immer was egal, ich bin eingeloggt, normalerweise liegt da nix.
Genau, also meine drei China Seiten der Wahl, um billiges Elektronikzeug einzukaufen.
Name liegt, Max, ja, Hi Max.
Also meine top drei Seiten, wo ich immer einkaufe in China, China-Kram.
Das ist nicht die exklusiven Seiten allerdings.
Hauptsächlich, das ist AliExpress, GearBest und sieht auch alles relativ ähnlich aus.
Und das beste Seite, Banggood, ich finde Banggood hört sich so ein bisschen hier an.
Aber sie meinen damit wahrscheinlich, dass man, ich weiß nicht was sie damit meinen.
Die H-Gate habe ich noch nix bestellt, ich habe ein paar China-Shops schon bestellt.
Das sind aber so die drei großen eigentlich.
Die H-Gate habe ich noch nicht bestellt, aber die sind öfters auch in den Suchanfragen drinne.
Sind das Grill, sind das die Dropshipper, wo die ganzen Dropshipper sind, die H-Gate.
Okay, also die denken schon mal, ich bin sehr interessiert an weiblicher Sommerbekleidung.
Ja, es gibt zig, zig, zig China-Seiten.
Allerdings, den besten Namen hat eindeutig Banggood.
Da wird man ordentlich gebankt.
Zwargon, die habe ich gestern auch gefunden.
Siehe hier, die hatte ich auch gestern gefunden.
Das Problem mit der Lib ist, die ist Node.js exklusiv.
Also das ist eine Node.js-Lib, die kann man nicht im Browser verwenden.
Und ich muss die ja im Browser verwenden.
Sollte man die doch irgendwie im Browser verwenden können, dann mache ich das damit.
Aber so wie es für mich aussieht, kann man die nicht im Browser verwenden, sondern nur Node.
Ich lasse mich aber gerne eines besseren belehren.
Das Pepega-Board aktualisiert übrigens nicht automatisch.
Schon jemals, das ist richtig praktisch hier das Teil.
Das ist richtig nice.
Sonst hätte ich die Frage übersehen vom Mond Everest.
Jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Schon jemals Pakete vom Zoll abgefangen und versenden die von DE EU.
Das kommt drauf an, also ja, ich hatte schon einige Pakete beim Zoll.
Allerdings, aus China kann ich mich jetzt noch nicht dran erinnern.
Ich will es nicht ausschließen, allerdings, aus den USA landet der Kram immer beim Zoll.
Die China-Händler haben anscheinend perfektioniert, die Sachen ordentlich zu deklarieren, sodass
sie nicht vom Zoll festgehalten werden.
Wer weiß, was die da draufschreiben, wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Blödsinn.
So, und ob die DE EU versenden, hängt von folgendem ab.
Man kann mal angenommen, wir suchen jetzt mal bei Banggood irgendwas, wir suchen jetzt
mal keine Ahnung, USB, wir suchen jetzt einfach irgendwas, wo es drei Milliarden Seiten gibt
mit USB.
Und dann kann man hier oben irgendwo auswählen, Warehouse, und dann kann man sagen EU Warehouse.
So, und jetzt hat man quasi alles, was direkt von EU verschickt wird.
Allerdings ist das auch ein bisschen fake, weil wir jetzt zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung,
gehen wir jetzt mal hier irgendwie auf irgend so ein Aluino, ja.
Und jetzt sieht man, okay, in dem Fall stimmt's, ich nehm's zurück, in dem Fall stimmt's,
da wird oftmals auch ein bisschen Blödsinn angezeigt, also man stellt auf EU Warehouse
und guckt danach und stellt fest, es kommt doch aus China oder Russland.
Vielleicht ist ja Russland Warehouse bei den EU Warehouse, keine Ahnung.
Was ich merkwürdig finde, dass es einen franzosen Warehouse gibt, ist doch French, oder?
Wir stellen mal, wir stellen mal auf Französisch um.
Ey, das ist immer die gleiche Playlist, das geht mir auf den Sack, ich brauch jetzt irgendwas
anderes.
Gaming Mix, Dubstep, wupp wupp wupp, besser gesagt.
Ja, das geht auch.
Cute Chat, cute as fuck ist der Chat hier, cute Chat, cute Chat, oh man, alter Twitch
ist das schon der normale.
So, jetzt haben wir auf französisches Warehouse umgestellt und tatsächlich, ich find's ja
aber wieder geil, ne?
Was, was gibt's für, das ist wieder voll, es gibt All Warehouses, Hong Kong, USA, EU
und Frankreich.
Als wären die Franzosen nicht in der Lage, im EU Warehouse zu bestellen, ja, UK würde
ich ja noch verstehen jetzt, in Zukunft, was auch immer, das muss man nicht verstehen,
das muss man nicht verstehen.
Browser, Browsify, ja, hab ich schon gelesen, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, aber das Pepega
Board ist echt nice, das kann ich sagen, okay, Frage beantwortet, zack, vergesse ich nichts.
Das lasse ich einfach mal drin stehen, dass ich das nächste Mal dran denke, sehr, sehr
nice.
Okay, also, ich brauch mal ein paar Sachen aus China, und zwar das erste, wo ich schon
eine ganze Weile danach suche, sind, um, wenn viel drei Videos da ist, oh, ist das schon
lange her, ähm, zwar, ich brauch ein paar Sachen aus China, wo ich jetzt schon ganz
lang danach suche, und letztens in der Suchmaschine was gefunden hab, sind Kabel, allerdings,
ähm, nur in Rot und nur in Schwarz, oder in Single, in Single Farbe suche ich welche,
wie alt bist du jetzt, ich bin 21, wir werden alt, 21, äh, ich werd, ich werd nächsten
Monat 35, also, 21, alt, äh, nächste Woche 35, äh, so, ich brauch diese Sorte von Kabel,
allerdings hätt ich die gerne, weil, es gibt, die haben immer nur diese Mischungen, ja,
die haben immer nur diese, die haben immer nur diese Streifen, wo alle möglichen Kabelfarben
drin sind.
Ich hätte gerne als Kabelfarben, ich hätte ganz viele rote gerne, und ganz viel schwarze
hätt ich gerne, Twitch Chat, kommt gar nicht auf die Idee, ne, ähm, und dann vielleicht
noch ne Rolle, ne Rolle irgendwie gelber und blauer, das ist, das reicht, wir grünen vielleicht
und den Rest brauch ich alles gar nicht, und ich hab letztens in dem China Shop gesehen,
dass die, entcreme dir das doch selber, ah, das könnt ich im Prinzip machen, ah, da hab
ich keinen Bock drauf, ich hab lieber, ich hab lieber, ich glaub, ich hab sogar ne Zange
für DuPort Kabel, ähm, DuPort Kabel, DuPort Wires, DuPort Jumper Kabel, wie auch immer
das Zeug genau heißt, ich hab sogar glaub ich irgendwo ne Zange dafür, ich hab mir
mal so ein paar Zangen, Krimpsets gekauft, für alles mögliche, äh, Netzwerk Kabel,
DuPort Kabel, ähm, Ader Endhülsen Krimp Ding, hab ich nicht einmal verwendet, aber hab
ich ne Box, ganz, Ader, ich wusste bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt gar nicht mal, dass es Ader
Endhülsen, was hieß, Moment, hieß das überhaupt so, wusste bis dahin gar nicht, dass es sowas
überhaupt gibt, Ader Endhülsen, tatsächlich, ich wusste, wie gesagt, ich wusste immer,
dass es das gibt, also immer, zumindest, das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch, was gucken,
das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch, wenn man, äh, die, ich zeig euch das auch, sieht, da
macht man Kabel rein, und, ähm, also, Kabel, Solitzen Kabel, so, so, so, so welche macht
man da rein, genau, so welche, da macht man das drüber und dann krimpt man das fest,
und dann gibt es einfach einen viel festeren und größeren Kontakt, den man dann reinschrauben
kann, das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch, hab ich aber noch nie verwendet, freust du dich
auf den Moment, wenn Bad Company 3 als Trailer erscheint, unglaublich, äh, ich hab ein Tool,
das vom Netzwerk Kabel, ähm, krimpen, allerdings, ist das kacke, das ist so viel rumgefädelt
und gefuddelt, da hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, aber nur fertig, Netzwerk Kabel,
ok, so, und zwar, ich hätte gerne, und das hab ich letztens untersucht, ah ja, nee, das
sind Kabelbinder, genau, sowas hätte ich im Endeffekt gerne, ich hätte gerne einen
Haufen fertig, fertig gekrimmter Kabel in diesen Farben, genau, in diesen Farben hätte
ich das gerne, und ich hab's keinen Bock selber zu krimpen, gefuddelt da, äh, wo hab ich
das denn gesehen, komplett in schwarz gab's die und in rot, dann doch AliExpress, ja, ja
nice, das brauch ich, das brauch ich, Pock, Moment, ich muss mir meinen eigenen Ordner
machen, äh, add folder, China, China, wo ist der China-Folder, China-Folder, speichern,
China, das brauch ich, genau sowas suche ich, einfach ne Bünde, was sind denn das hier,
200 Stück, das ist gut, genau, genau das was ich brauch, am besten wär's, wenn die noch
hier die lila Dinger weglassen würden, die braunen Dinger, die einfach doppelt so viel
schwarz und rote Kabel hin machen, die brauch ich, haben die sonst noch was, ja gut, das
ist zum selber machen, oder, was ist denn das, da fehlt die Hülse drumherum, ne, das ist
ja Mist, halb fertig, ja, das easy, das wird bestellt, AliExpress, 5 Pack, dann hab ich
die nächsten Jahre Ruhe, sind nur Female to Female, zum größten Teil brauch ich auch
Female to Female, weil die ganzen GPIO Pins sind Pins und die meisten Sensor sind auch
Pins, ja, aber du hast recht, ab und zu mal braucht man auch noch einen Female to Male
oder Male to Female, Female to Male, Black, optimal, ist auch gekauft, China, AliExpress
regelt, perfekt, das sind random Farben, nice, ok, AliExpress hat sich schonmal rentiert,
das muss, das wird bestellt, auf jeden Fall brauch ich, von diesen Kabeln kann man generell
nie genug haben, so mal in das Pepega Board gucken, ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab, Battlefield
3 haben wir beantwortet, Grimpen selber machen wir nicht, ja wie gesagt auf Bad Company 3
freu ich mich übertrieben, wobei ich hab das Gefühl, ich lass mich mit Bad Company 3 übelst
halten und am Ende wirds zacken, weil die einfach verlernt haben, wie man ordentliche
Battlefield Games macht, oh eine Donation, da kann ich ja gleich noch mehr China Zeug
bestellen, 5 Euro, ich hoffe du bist auf der Gamescom 2019, dann geb ich dir ein Bier
aus für den tollen Video, ich hab jetzt nicht weiter lesen können, weil die Nachricht verschwunden
ist, aber ich bin nicht auf der Gamescom 2019, geh nicht mal auf die Gamescom, unglaublich
sinnlos Messe mittlerweile, hast du am 13.7. Geburtstag, nee ich hab gesagt nächsten Monat,
nächsten Monat ist nicht der 13.7., ich hab am August Geburtstag, 26, na gut 10 plus
9 Jahre Unterschied dann, ja aber Bad Company 3 bin ich schon ultra gehyped drauf, ich hoffe
das, ich mein es deutet alles drauf hin, aber man weiß ja nie, ob es dann am Ende auch
so wird ne, so ok also das erste China Ding haben wir schon gefunden, als nächstes wollt
ich mal schauen, ob ich günstig noch nen zweiten Staubsauger Roboter krieg von denen die ich
hab, hab ich zugemacht aus Versehen, also bei Banggood schonmal nicht, jetzt hier war's,
oh die sind nochmal ganz schön unterschiedlich im Preis, Banggood, ja bester Name ne, da muss
es klatschen bei Banggood, viel zu teuer, viel zu teuer, 43% off und dann immer noch
379, wollen die uns verarschen, ach es ist viel zu teuer, viel viel viel zu teuer, ach
Moment Dollar, aber es sind Euro auch zu teuer, das ist ja bei Amazon billiger, warum immer
ich diesen komischen Kack Handyhalter krieg, äh, warum ist das so teuer auf einmal, ich
hab meinen für 250 oder so gekriegt, zwar aber gerade im Angebot, aber das ist ein Unterschied
ob 250 oder 420, the fuck, alter lan, was ist hier los, warum ist das so teuer, mit WISH
Funktion, ja aber die verwende ich nicht, der ist richtig gut, soll ich euch mal das
Web Interface zeigen vom Staubsauger Roboter, äh, vorher muss ich noch sagen, äh, vorher
muss ich euch noch zeigen was das für ein Web Interface ist, das ist ja nicht das offizielle
Web Interface, weil offiziell hat das Ding kein Web Interface, so sieht das Teil in Großaufnahme
aus, ähm, hier hinten, oder hier hinten, ich kann mir gar nicht merken auf welcher Seite
der Behälter ist, da hat man einen Einschub für Wasser und einen Einschub für den Mülleimer,
allerdings ist der Mülleimer nicht sonderlich groß und man kann hier auch so Lappen dran
machen, verwende ich aber nicht, äh, ich zeige euch jetzt noch das Web Interface, dass das
Web Interface drauf kommt, das ist ein Open Source Guitar Projekt, oh ich muss mal gucken,
gibt es eine neue Version, die ich noch installieren müsste, nö, ich hab nämlich schon Master
installiert, nicht das letzte Release, bist du jetzt schon zu faul zum Saugen, man vermeidet
mit Staubsauger Roboter nicht, dass man saugen muss, man muss seltener saugen, das ist schon
mal nicht schlecht, so, Web Interface muss ich mal kurz raussuchen, und da, da, dass man
das Web Interface darauf verwenden kann, muss man halt den Roboter flaschen, das Flaschen
ist ein bisschen abenteuerlicher Vorgang, ist auch schon jetzt ein paar Wochen her, wo ich
das gemacht hab, ich hab's ja auf Twitter gepostet, ähm, ist ein bisschen abenteuerlich
gewesen, ich überleg grad, wie das noch mal funktioniert hat, man musste, genau, man musste
sich das Repo irgendwie runterladen, dann musste man irgendwelche Scripts ausführen, dann hat
man einen Raspberry gebraucht, über den konnte man das dann irgendwie flaschen, war ein bisschen
abenteuerlich, aber nachdem was man gemacht hat, war es eigentlich, äh, ziemlich, ziemlich
easy, genau, so, und das Web Interface sieht folgendermaßen aus, muss nur gucken, da ich
jetzt nicht aus Versehen wieder irgendwas leake oder so, ähm, Web Interface sieht so
aus, kann man natürlich auch wunderbar mit, mit Tablet bedienen, also das, ich bin jetzt
gerade auf meinem Staubsauger-Roboter drauf, wer sich das fragt, also wir haben, wir haben
ja hier gerne Web Interfaces und geflächte Chinasachen, letztens waren wir per Web Interface
auf meiner Steckdosenleiste drauf, auf einer der vier Steckdosenleisten drauf, und heute
sind wir per Web Interface auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter drauf, eben, die sind im Jahr 2019, ja, da
hat auch der Staubsauger-Roboter ein Web Interface, und auf der Steckdosenleiste, ja, Steckdosenleiste
haben wir letztens geflasht, mit, ähm, Open Source Firmware von, von GitHub, und jetzt
kann man es, ähm, remote schalten, über das Web Interface, beziehungsweise über, über
API, das ist quasi für 29 Euro, ne, ne, vierfach IP Steckdosenleiste, sowas ist halt
übelst teuer, wenn man sich das fertig kauft, tja, deine Steckdosenleiste hat kein Prozessor,
die China Steckdosenleiste hat ein ESP8266 drauf, deswegen lässt die sich auch so schön
flashen.
Streamt und redet über Staubsauger, wo andere Games spielen, spiele habe ich heute Vormittag,
drei Stunden, wie heißt denn die Steckdosenleiste, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Steckdosenleiste,
ich glaube wir haben ein Kommando dafür, Steckdosenleiste oder Steckdose oder so, Ausrufezeichen Steckdose,
darum Steckdosenleiste, äh, äh, ok, einkauf schon durch, ne, gerade dabei, ich muss mal
gucken wie ist das denn das Kommando, weil ich weiß selbst nicht mehr wie das Ding hieß,
Steckerleiste, Ausrufezeichen Steckerleiste, ist es, Steckerleiste, hier, hier ist die,
ist das, äh, wer wissen will wie wir das geflashed haben, kann einfach im Archiv gucken, ähm,
dann findet ihr den Stream wo wir das geflashed haben, die kostet 29 Euro und ähm, lässt
sich mit das Motor flashen, das Ding kann man auf die Steckdosenleiste drauf flashen,
total einfach, man braucht einfach nur einen Raspberry und einen Skript, das startet man
und den Rest macht der Skript, das ist easy, man könnte, so teuer ist das, ne, 29 Euro
ist ok, in China ist der Kram auch nicht viel billiger, also 29 Euro ist, geht in Ordnung,
beim Ikea für 5 Euro, da hab ich meine Zweifel, dass es beim Ikea eine Steckdosenleiste gibt
für 5 Euro, die man mit das Motor flashen kann und dann, ähm, Remote schalten kann,
da hab ich irgendwie meine Zweifel, wenn ja schickt Ikea Link, Link all didn't happen
mehr, man braucht nen Raspberry mit WLAN, genau, brauchst nen Raspberry mit WLAN unbedingt,
sonst gehts nicht, da brennt doch die Bude weg, wie kommst du denn auf sowas, die hat
selbstverständlich, ähm, alle notwendigen Prüfsiegel, Monka Smoke, die hat sie wirklich,
allerdings haben die die einfach nur aufgedruckt, geh ich mal von aus, und was bringt das, naja,
du kannst die Steckdosenleiste schalten, ohne dass du dabei sein musst, kannst auch über
deine Heimautomatisierung schalten lassen, Steckdosenleisten, schaltbare Steckdosenleiste
braucht man immer, ähm, warum ich die flashen muss, ist ganz einfach, oder musste, ist ganz
einfach, ähm, die unterstützt zwar Alexa und Gedöns, standardmäßig allerdings nur
mit ner Smartphone App und auch nur mit der offiziellen Smartphone App und auch nur über
die China Cloud, also es ist nicht etwa so, dass man quasi mit seinem Handy die Steckdosenleiste
schalten kann, nee nee, man lädt sich die offizielle Steckdosenleisten App runter, die
muss sich dann pairen mit der China Cloud und dann schaltest du deine Steckdosenleiste
mit dem Smartphone, wo du daneben stehst, über die Cloud in China an und aus, das ist einfach
nur hirnrissig.
Ähm, deswegen hab ich die geflashed, jetzt kann ich per Webinterface drauf, ähm, genau,
per Webinterface drauf und die Sachen einfach an und ausschalten, easy, und auch mein Home
Assistant kann über, also meine Heimautomatisierungslösung, kann dann drauf zugreifen, an und ausschalten,
genau, aber zurück zum Staubsauger Roboter.
In China geht der Server da und ich hab ne Stromausfalle, ja so ungefähr ist das, wenn
du was schalten willst und die China Cloud ist weg, dann gehts nicht, das gleiche Problem
haben übrigens die ganzen Leute, die sich nen Nestthermostat gekauft haben, die können
ihre Heizung nicht einschalten, wenn der Server nicht da ist.
Das ist unglaublich bescheuert.
Und noch viel schlimmer, die Nest API wird eingestellt, jetzt haben sie direkt gelitten.
Christi Gelmann hat dann die LHF, ähm, genau, jetzt zurück zum Staubsauger Roboter, hallo
Nick Kitz, ne, Nin Kitz, zurück zum Staubsauger Roboter, also wenn man den geflasht hat,
mit Fale Tudor, übelster Zungenbrecher der Name, doch, war es letztens, jaja, die Probleme
gibt es immer mal wieder Leute, die Cloudlösungen verwenden, dass sie dann ihre Heizung nicht
ein und ausschalten können, sowas kommt eigentlich laufend vor.
Beim größeren Ziel, beim kleineren Ziel, was macht eigentlich der Friseur, man ausruft
seinen Friseur, da hat er dann einen eigenen Stream, in dem er öfters MMOs streamt.
So, ähm, zurück zum Staubsauger, jetzt endlich mal zeigen, ähm, das ist ein schönes Webinterface,
lässt sich gut per Tablet bedienen, wie man hier sieht, ne, das ist so das typische Hamburger
Menü, wie sich das nennt, ähm, man kann hier einstellen, Start, Stop, Pause, er soll
zurück zum Dock fahren, ich mein, aktuell ist er am Dock dran, ähm, und ich hab das
vorm Stream schon mal vorbereitet, das ganze, weil ich hab die Karte gelöscht, normalerweise
würde man hier jetzt quasi den kompletten Grundriss und alles vom Haus sehen, ähm,
der hat so einen Laserscanner oben drauf und scannt die Räume ab, ähm, wenn man will,
dass er die Karte vergisst, oh, jetzt hab ich da drauf geklickt, ich hoffe, der fährt
jetzt nicht los, ähm, wenn man, wenn man will, dass er die Karte vergisst, ist ganz einfach,
einfach hochheben, Knopf drücken, dann vergisst er die Karte, genau, also man hat hier vorne,
kannst du das Ding starten, stoppen, man kann, ganz, ganz nützlich ist, man kann, ähm,
Areas definieren, hab ich jetzt hier eingestellt, ähm, unter der Treppe unten Wohnzimmer, äh,
oben Flur, unten Schlafzimmer, Kirche, Bad, Bad oben, äh, oben Flur, oben Wohnzimmer und
oben Schlafzimmer und nachdem der ja eine Karte drin hat, klickt man dann eins davon
an und er fährt halt direkt hin, die kommt ja in die verschiedenen Stockwerke gar nicht,
den muss er tragen, da hab ich noch nichts, den muss er tragen, genau, hier kann man die
unterschiedlichen Zonen einstellen, äh, hier kann man auch, wenn man will, auf dem Tablet
das Ding manuell kontrollen, also man kann den mit dem Tablet wie eine Fernsteuerung
durch die Wohnung fahren, ja und hier hat man irgendwelche Settings, also das ist ganz,
ganz nett das Webinterface, ja, oh, glaub jetzt hab ich ihn irgendwohin geschickt, ok
was auch immer, ich mach jetzt noch mal zu, ja, und das ist nämlich der Grund warum ich
den zweiten will, das ist ein Grund warum ich den zweiten will, ich will nämlich einen
für oben und einen für unten haben, weil das Ding spackt immer rum, wenn man das hochhebt
und Knöpfe drückt und dann merkt es, dass es nicht mehr im richtigen Stockwerk ist und
dann vergisst es die Map und baut die Map neu auf und so, das ist, das ist ziemlich
blöd und ich hab mir gedacht eigentlich hab ich auch gar keinen Bock den grabenhohen
runter zu tragen, sondern ich kauf mir einfach einen zweiten, allerdings ich kauf mir keinen
zweiten für 420 Euro, das seh ich nicht ein, ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken was ich dafür
bezahlt hab, ich bilde mir einen 250 oder sowas, das war richtig günstig, deswegen
hab ich den damals auch bestellt, S50, Roborock, ach nee fuck den hab ich bei alternate bestellt
ich kann jetzt gar nicht nachgucken, er bestellste einmal was nicht bei Amazon schon kannst du
nicht mal nachgucken, für ein microcontroller, wo kann man da ein Arduino Starterkit empfehlen,
ich würd gar kein Arduino nehmen, ich würd mir einen, dieser kack Handyhalter, ich muss
den löschen aus der Historie, ich komm immer auf diesen dämlichen Handyhalter raus, wenn
ich auf Amazon gehe, ich würd gar keinen empfehlen, als Einstieg ist eigentlich sowas
hier nicht schlecht, rein zum basteln, ist das hier ganz praktisch, wobei das viel zu
teuer ist gerade bei Amazon wie ich sehe, normalerweise kriegst du ein Board für 4 Euro oder sowas
oder du holst dir ne, ja hier 5 Stück 20 Euro, die sind ein bisschen teuer gerade auf Amazon,
aber es geht, also ich würde mir einen ESP32 oder einen ESP866 holen, das ist zwar kein
original Arduino, aber das ist Arduino kompatibel, echt geht das, shift entfernen, ja aber es
bleibt immer noch im, oder auch nicht, ach vielleicht muss ich das nicht in der anonymen
Session machen, vielleicht hat das jetzt schon gelöscht, bloß ja hab ich doch, warst du
grad, warst du grad nicht da, ich hab grad das Webinterface von meinem Staubsaugerroboter
gezeigt, dafür lauflöschen, ja du warst ab, ja ich kanns dir nochmal zeigen, ich kanns
dir nochmal zeigen, was wars, 122168, 1.107, ich habs vergessen, ach 60, 107 wars ne, 60,
genau, da, da ist die Übersichtung an Staubsauger, ach ja was auch noch ganz cool ist, man kann
einstellen wie stark das saugen soll und der hat nen Teppichmodus, wo man einstellen kann,
dass er Teppiche stärker saugt, das ist wirklich ganz cool, es gibt ne deutsche Sprachpaket,
hab ich eben noch gar nicht erzählt, es gibt ne deutsche Sprachpaket, weil vor allem Grills
sind da ja sehr wählerisch, wenn das Ding englisch redet, oh nö das wär doof, wenn das Ding deutsch
redet und sagt er, wenn du auf find drückst sagt er, hallo hier bin ich, hallo hier bin
ich, hallo, also sagt er halt, wenn du das deutsche Sprachpaket drauf machst, also Nico
ich kann dir nur empfehlen, flash das Ding, du brauchst nen Raspberry Pi mit WLAN dazu,
es ist aber relativ easy und ich würde nicht Firmware Aktualisierung machen, ich würde
auf keinen Fall die Firmware Aktualisierung machen, weil die sind gerade dabei die Sachen
zu blocken, mit Custom Firmware, also auf keinen Fall Firmware Update machen, oh du brauchst
nen Raspberry mit WLAN unbedingt, swingt, ansonsten ist die Anleitung hier eigentlich
ganz gut, was ich gemacht hab, ist ich verwende nicht das letzte Release, sondern ich verwende
das was im Master drinnen ist, der kann ein paar mehr Sachen, der hat zum Beispiel im
Webinterface drinnen, dass du direkt im Webinterface Regionen anlegen kannst, wo der Roboter hinfahren
soll, wann kommt neues Video, wenn ich Bock auf YouTube hab, schloss mal auf, falls noch
einer was wissen will nachher, so, ja, also wer hatte nochmal, der Zagornet hat gefragt,
also ich würde nen ESP2866 oder nen ESP32 empfehlen, um mit Microcontroller zu euch
anzufangen, super easy zu programmieren, Arduino kompatibel, hat USB und alles schon
on Board, das heißt du brauchst auch keinen Programmieradapter mehr oder irgendwas und
was finde ich jetzt auch ein ganz guter Vorteil ist, die ESPs sind 3,3 Volt und die meisten
Sensoren sind auch 3,3 Volt, Arduino ist 5 Volt.
Hey Edras Off Topic, aber welches Rack hast du, ähm, ich hatte mir damals bei Rack Magic
oder so was gekauft, Shop sieht aus wie 1995, ähm, ich hatte mir bei denen was kleines
gekauft, ich glaube das da, nee, meins hat 14 Höheneinheiten, 12, nee 12 Höheneinheiten,
irgendwas von denen hatte ich, allerdings fertiges Rack und nicht so ein, so ein, so
ein Kaster, ja, Kaster hab ich, allerdings war das damals gefühlt auch nicht so teuer,
irgendwie ist alles viel teurer geworden, also man kann richtig viel Geld sparen, wenn
man sich nen Rack sucht, ich hatte die Antwort, ich wollte nen besonders kleines Rack, also
ich wollte eins was nicht so tief ist, das ist nämlich nur 144, äh, 440 Millimeter,
also 44 Zentimeter tief, lassen sich mit der Custom Firma im Roborock die Fall Detection
Sensoren abschalten, ich glaube nicht, wahrscheinlich musste das manuell machen, ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass es an sich geht, an einem Chatbot machst du heute nicht weiter, vielleicht
am Ende noch ein bisschen was, allerdings funktioniert das Chatbot jetzt ziemlich gut,
sogar mit, sogar mit Emotes, wobei das nicht an mir liegt, dass es mit Emotes funktioniert,
allerdings man kann, bei Racks kann man relativ viel Geld sparen, wenn man keine Sonderwünsche
hat in Form von soll nur 44 Zentimeter tief sein, soll nur so und so hoch sein, gebrauchte
Racks sind relativ günstig, weil wenn einer nen Rack loswerden will, dann will er da meistens
nicht viel für haben, wenn man nach gebrauchten Racks guckt, und wenn man was kompaktes haben
will, was sich auch zu lohnen schaut, sind Audiorecks, Audiorecks sehen halt nicht so
servertechnisch aus, allerdings sind das auch 19 Zoll Racks, wo man auch Sachen reinstellen
kann, sehen halt nicht so servermäßig aus, aber ich meine, wen juckt die Optik, das ist
ein Gestell, also mit Audiorecks kann man auch ein bisschen was sparen, so, guck mal
mal, was unser Pepega-Board macht, ich muss die Fragen abhaken, sonst komme ich überhaupt
nicht hinterher, haben wir beantwortet, haben wir beantwortet, haben wir, haben wir beantwortet,
kann man den Zauberstaube in Home Assistant integrieren, ja klar, kannst du machen, wieso
der sich nicht automatisch Refreshed, weil ich Refreshed auf Null gestellt hab, kann
man den Staubsauger zufällig in Home, kann man machen, habe ich schon gesagt, ja vielleicht
seine Freundin, na gut, ganz Steckdosenleiste, das haben wir, kann so bei der Steckdosenleiste
die einzelnen Ports schalten, oder alle auf einmal, jeden einzelnen Port kann ich schalten,
inklusive USB, allerdings die USB-Charger kann ich nur alle, oder kein ein und ausschalten,
also ich hab in der Steckdosenleiste 5 Schalter für 4 Geräte und die 4 USB-Ports, kannst
du mir sagen, wie ich im Home Assistant sagen soll, welchen DNS-Server er fest benutzen
soll, der nimmt normalerweise den, den du, was hast, was hast denn du, hast du Home Assistant,
hast du die Hass.io Geschichte, oder hast du Linux mit drauf installiert, oder Hass.io
auf Linux, ach du hast Hass.os, stimmt, hast ja grad einen Link gepostet, hab ich noch nicht
verwendet, weiß ich nicht, replace the following configuration, wieso steht doch da, oder meinst
du, wo die Datei ist, wo man das replacen muss, ich hab als Staubsauger-Roboter, hab ich einen
Roborock S50, ich kenn das so erst nicht, ich weiß nicht, welche Datei das ist, allerdings,
na hier, inside config-network, my-network, slash config, slash network, my-network, in
dieser Datei musst du das editieren, config-network, my-network, keine Endung, einfach ein Pfeil,
was my-network heißt, gar keine Endung, Endung ist eh so ein komisches Windows-Konzept, also
unter Ledigungen gibt es auch viele Files, die keine Endung haben, die meisten Files
haben eigentlich keine Endung, haben wir beantwortet, hattest du mal Kontakt mit P-Zwitten, nee,
hast du Smartlampen, ich hab einen im Einsatz, und ich hab ein paar Relays für Schalter,
ansonsten bin ich kein allzu großer Fan von Smartlampen, das hab ich auch schon öfters
erzählt im Stream, deswegen erzähl ich das nur mal ganz kurz, du hast das Problem, wenn
du Smartlampen hast, dass du die immer noch an der Lampe dran hast, die du mit dem Lichtschalter
ausschalten kannst, und wenn du mit dem Lichtschalter ausschaltest, ist die smarte Lampe nicht mehr
smart, deswegen ist es viel intelligenter finde ich, also viel mehr Big-brainiger, also
viel mehr 900 IQ-mäßig, wenn du, das war jetzt auch wieder Twitch-Chat ohne Ende, wenn
du die Lichtschalter smart machst und nicht die Lampe, Lichtschalter ausbauen ist auch
keine Alternative, weil Lichtschalter ausbauen bedeutet man kann die Lampe nicht mal an dem
Schalter ein- und ausschalten, und du willst ja oftmals einfach in den Raum reingehen,
Lichtschalter drücken, und Licht soll angehen, du willst nicht erst suchen wo dein Tablet
ist um das Licht einzuschalten, du willst beides machen können, du willst Zugriff von
deinem Tablet auf die Lichtsteuerung haben, du willst dass deine Heimautomatisierung auf
deine Lichtsteuerung zugreifen kann, und du willst immer noch, wenn du auf einen Kackschalter
drückst, dass das Licht angeht, deswegen kann ich als Relay für, als Relay für Lichtschalter
oder Relay für Lampe kann ich eigentlich nur das hier empfehlen, das ist ziemlich gut,
Shelly One, das beste an dem Ding ist, na gut das da Open Source hinten dran steht ist
egal, man kann es entweder mit das Motor flashen, oder aber man kann es einfach auch mit der
Stockfirmware verwenden, die keinerlei Cloud Anbindung braucht.
Die Domain ist absolut next level, also bei Shelly haben jetzt nicht so die aller cleversten
Leute dran gesessen, weil eines der Hauptverkaufsargumente für diese Shelly-Dinger, für diese Shelly-Software,
für diese Shelly-Relays ist eben, dass sie keine Cloud brauchen, da ist es natürlich
wahnsinnig big brain, seine Domain Shelly.cloud zu nennen, also wie gesagt das Hauptverkaufsargument
ist, die Dinger brauchen keine Cloud, das ist schon ein bisschen dämlich, aber ok,
man kann sie connecten mit der Shelly-Cloud, aber das Hauptverkaufsargument schlechthin
von den Dinger ist, dass sie keine Cloud Anbindung brauchen.
Hast du ein Bild von deinem Setup?
Nein habe ich nicht, außerdem ist mein Setup auch ziemlich im Haus verteilt, das ist halt
Smart Home, da gibt es halt kein Bild von einer Sache.
Ok, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben, wir haben jetzt ja viel viel viel
erzählt, äh sollte man für, übrigens Leute, es wäre gut, wenn ihr Fragen habt, wo ich
was zu sagen soll, schreibt Adwoblos dazu, weil dann kriegt es mein Fragentool mit, da
kann ich nichts mehr übersehen, wenn ihr nicht Adwoblos dabei schreibt, dann muss ich
zufällig gerade in Chat gucken, dass ich es sehe, nur wenn der Adwoblos irgendwo in der
Frage steht, dann taucht sie auf und es ist gelockt.
Sollte man für Smart Home ein eigenes abgeschottetes Subnetz machen?
Ja, man sollte mehrere abgeschottete Subnetz machen.
Also soll ich mal kurz aufmalen, wie ich das empfehlen würde, wie man sein Netzwerk daheim
einrichten sollte, wenn man, also mit und ohne Smart Home, also was ich machen würde
ist folgendes, äh wenn Roller vorhanden schon automatisiert oder vor zu automatisieren,
ja beides, ich hab so Plastikrollen von Sompfie heißen die glaube ich und ich hab noch so
welche so dicke aus Holz, ähm die Sompfie Dinger hab ich schon automatisiert, die gehen
über, Alter war das, war das gerade Erdbeben oder was, es hat gerade voll gewackelt im
Haus, was war das denn, ist auch kein Zug vorbeigefahren, Moment, nee ohne Scheiß jetzt,
ich mein es war gerade ein schlimmes Erdbeben, es hat voll gewackelt gerade, wartet mal kurz.
Hat sich erledigt, Katze umgefallen, so dick ist die auch noch nicht, ich mein die Katze
ist zwar dick, aber nicht so dick, ok, genau ich wollt mal Netzwerk aufmalen und noch ganz
schnell was zu den Rollos sagen, also die Sompfie Dinger hab ich automatisiert, die
sind relativ easy gewesen mit, ja so ganz normalem RF, Funk, 433 Megahertz ist das glaube ich
gewesen, ist recht einfach gewesen, ähm die Holzrollos hab ich ein Prototyp hier am Start
um das zu automatisieren und zwar hab ich einen, hab ich das hier gekauft, Amazon, zeigt
das, nicht komm, DE, Duofernen, so ein Ding, ich weiß nicht ob das der ist, irgendeiner
mit, irgendeinen davon hab ich gekauft, weil der hat ne auf GitHub, auf GitHub gibt es
eine Library für das Ding, natürlich nicht offiziell vom Hersteller, ne ist klar, hab
ich gefunden und man muss sich einfach nur den Duofernen USB Stick kaufen, kostet 30
Euro oder so das Teil, und damit mit dem USB Stick, wenn man ihn irgendwie findet, mit
diesem USB Stick und, Alter warum ist der Scheiß alles so teuer geworden, ok es wird
schon billiger, ok 30 Euro waren übertrieben, 40 Euro, 40, 50 Euro, so und das kann man
mit der Library und dem passenden USB Stick, kann man diesen Gurtwickler steuern und er
macht glaube ich bis zu 30 Kilo, baut natürlich den Stromanschluss und damit, da hab ich aber
nur ein Prototyp am Start gerade, hab ich noch nicht im Haus eingebaut, ok Netzwerk
wollte ich mal, also wir machen erstmal wie ich Netzwerk daheim einteilen würde, wird
irgendwas gemacht heute, ich wollte eigentlich in China einkaufen und irgendwie sind wir
jetzt bei Gott und der Welt von Technikkrams wieder gelandet, eigentlich hatte ich vorhin
China einzukaufen und dann ein bisschen ESP32 Multithreading zu programmieren, also Netzwerk
mäßig würde ich folgendermaßen machen, wie machen wir das jetzt, am besten machen
wir so ein Kringel oder so, oder haben die schönere Symbole für Netzwerk, ein Firewall
Symbol, ein Router, ein Router Symbol brauchen wir noch, hier der routet er, er routet der
Router, also was ich machen würde ist, also was meine grundsätzliche Frage ist, wenn
man daheim Netzwerk betreibt, will man irgendwas von außen verwenden, kennst du gute Einfach
Steckdosen, die per Webinterface, nee, ich kenne nur die Steckdosenleiste die sich per
Webinterface steuern lässt, du kannst ja aber, wenn du eine richtig gute Steckdosenleiste
haben willst, was hältst du von einer C-Wave Steckdosenleiste, kostet 29 Euro, da brauchst
du aber halt einen C-Wave Stick und ein System was C-Wave kann, also wenn du es wirklich
per Webinterface willst, eine einfache Steckdosenleiste, die per Webinterface, die du flaschen kannst,
fällt mir nichts zu ein.
Das könnten wir, ey, das könnten wir echt mal machen, Twitch Plays Heimautomatisierung,
ich überlasse euch einfach, ich überlasse dem Twitch Chat einfach mal einen Tag, meine
Heimautomatisierung, mal gucken was der Twitch Chat macht.
Gerne in Sonoff kann man sich holen, allerdings ist in Sonoff keine Steckdosenleiste, so wirklich,
sondern, äh, oder keine Steckdose, in Sonoff, da musst du ja wirklich das Kabel aufschneiden
und reinmachen.
Also einfach reinstecken und so ist das nicht.
Na, es explodiert.
Okay, also Netzwerk, das erste was man sich fragen muss, wir machen jetzt mal hier,
Internet, und das machen wir rot, weil Internet ist böse, so, das erste was man sich fragen
muss, wenn das hier Internet ist hier und das hier Router der routet, möchte man irgendwas
von dem was hier dahinter ist, das hier dahinter machen wir mal intern, das teilen wir gleich
noch auf, möchte man in irgendeiner Art und Weise von da was da verwenden, ne, also
von intern nach extern ist ja kein Problem, Steckerleiste, Ausrufezeichen Steckerleiste
ist der richtige, richtige Command, ähm, wenn man vom Internet intern hinzugreifen
will, macht es das ein bisschen komplizierter, da muss man, muss man sich ein bisschen mehr
Gedanken machen.
Ähm, ja, VPN, VPN ist ja im Endeffekt ein eigenes Netz, was sei denn, man, man nimmt
das interne Netz mit, würde ich aber nicht machen, ich würde VPN in mein eigenes Netz
verfrachten.
Da kann man nämlich auch viel besser den Zugriff steuern, na, sonst klaut einer das
Handy und dann gleich Zugriff irgendwie aufs ganze Haus, also ich würde, ich würde VPN
schon, ok, gehen wir mal von aus, man möchte per VPN von außen, aber wir machen erstmal
den, ähm, den, den, den einfachsten Fall, so man hat ne, man hat ne Fritzbox, wobei
mit ner Fritzbox kommste halt leider nicht, kommste halt nicht leider weit, weil das einzige
was du mit ner Fritzbox machen kannst ist, ähm, intern, WLAN, das ist das gleiche Netz
und, ähm, Gast-WLAN, das ist das einzige was du mit ner Fritzbox machen kannst, ohne großartige,
viel mehr kannst du mit ner Fritzbox nicht einstellen, haste, haste nicht so viel Optionen.
So, ähm, das heißt ich würde schon mal gucken, dass man, die Fritzbox ist, ist, ist ein super,
ein super, ähm, Multifunktionskommunikationsgerät, ja, da kann man nichts zu sagen, die Fritzbox
ist toll, die kann deckt, die kann DSL einwahl, Kabelmodem einwahl, also für sowas ist die
super, da würde ich sie für verwenden, allerdings, ähm, als Router oder Firewall ist die Fritzbox
nicht so toll, deswegen ist es nicht verkehrt, man stellt sich noch nen Router hinten dran,
das ist generell das erste was ich machen würde, ich würde mir irgendwie nen günstlichen
Mikrotik-Router kaufen, oder aber, PFSense, wie einer gerade im Chat geschrieben hat, oder
IPCop oder sowas, wenn man noch nen alten Rechner hat, am einfachsten dürfte es allerdings
sein, wenn man nicht viel machen will, und man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen will,
da gehts dann nämlich letztendlich rum, weil umsonst ist das, äh, insofern nicht, Zeit-Einsatz
braucht das schon, ja, Fritzbox anstöpseln, paar Häkchen machen kann jeder, aber, ähm,
das ordentlich machen kann nicht jeder, ne, ähm, so, also das erste was ich machen würde,
ich würde mir nen zusätzlichen Router kaufen, der kommt dann hinter die Fritzbox, die Fritzbox
macht, äh, genau, macht VoIP, macht Deckt und macht, äh, Internet-Einwahl und das war's
im Großen und Ganzen schon, man kann sich überlegen, ob man die Fritzbox nicht vielleicht
auf VPN machen lässt, allerdings, das würde ich, eigentlich würde ich das alles den hier
machen lassen, also das erste was ich mir kaufen würde, und da ist man schon auf nen
ziemlich guten Weg, ist nen ordentlicher, nen ordentlicher Router, wenn man es nicht
selbst bauen will, würde ich ne Mikrotik-Kiste empfehlen, RouterOS ist nicht das einfachste,
ich zeig euch mal wie das Web-Interface aussieht, was man dann so kriegt, die sind übrigens
nicht teuer, ne, ich empfehle ja immer den hier, als Einsteiger-Router empfehle ich immer
den, den Hex-POE, ist nicht teuer, 50 Euro, das sind die falschen übrigens, irgendwie
60 Euro oder so, also ich würde, ich würde den Hex-POE nehmen, der ist eigentlich ziemlich
gut, da ne ordentliche CPU drinnen, du hast 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Ports und sogar noch nen FSP-Port,
falls man das jemals brauchen sollte, also den kann man empfehlen, das ist ein wirklich
super Ding, so und wenn man auf den Router drauf geht, so, das ist nicht mein Router,
das ist die offizielle Demo von Mikrotik, dann wird man erstmal erschlagen mit allen
möglichen Optionen, man muss sich ein paar Tutorials angucken, aber im Prinzip ist der
Kram nicht so schwierig, wenn man nicht abgedrehte Sachen machen will, wenn man anfängt irgendwie
zu sagen, hey ich hab zwei Router daheim und möchte OSPF machen, warum auch immer, dann
wird es ein bisschen komplizierter, aber die normalen Sachen, DHCP Server Netze anlegen
oder eben auch ein paar Firewall-Regeln anlegen, ist nicht so schwierig, auch nicht unter
Router-OS, man muss sich bloß ein bisschen mit beschäftigen, also das ist das erste was
ich machen würde, ich würde mir einen ordentlichen Router kaufen, dann würde ich ein internes
Netzwerk definieren und internes Netzwerk heißt bei mir, wir machen mal die IP-Kop-Farben,
die haben nämlich rot, blau, grün, internes Netzwerk heißt bei mir, das ist kein WLAN,
das ist Kabel, das ist ein internes Netzwerk, das kommt, da ist nochmal ein Switch dazwischen
oder so, was auch immer, mit einem Port kommt man ja wahrscheinlich nicht aus, das geht
an einen Port hier dran, das ist internes Netzwerk und fertig, wer kennt es nicht, OSPF im Heimbereich,
deswegen habe ich ja auch gerade so Spaß gesagt, das macht ja kein Mensch, genau und das ist
nur Kabel, das mache ich grün an der Stelle, weil das wirklich das sensibelste Netz ist,
was man hat, da ist das interne Nass dran, da ist die Desktop-Rechner dran, da ist quasi
so das Zeug dran, wo die sensibelsten Sachen drauf liegen, deswegen ist das ein Ding, wo
auch kein WLAN direkt reinkommt, sondern Kabel, vielleicht noch ein Switch, weil ich meine,
mit einem Port wird man nicht hinkommen, Kabel aus dem Mikrotik-Router raus, ein Switch dran
und da kann man dann alles mögliche anschließen, Drucker intern, Desktop-Rechner intern, ich
habe das Shield-TV noch beispielsweise dran, das ist bei mir auch intern, alles interne,
also das ist quasi das sicherste Netz, dementsprechend richtet man auch gleichermaßen noch eine Firewall-Regel
rein, dass dieses Netz ohne weitere Freischaltung immer und überall hin darf, das ist auch quasi
das Netz, von dem ihr dann alles andere administrieren könnt, da könnt ihr euch auch nicht mehr
aussperren, könnt einfach sagen, das interne Netz, dem vertraue ich, da kann man auch nur
dran, wenn man im Haus ist und dort an den Netzwerk-Ports rankommt, wir reden jetzt mal
nicht von Port-Security oder sowas, das ist im Heimbereich alles viel zu Overkill, man
muss es nicht total übertreiben, also man könnte das machen, man könnte beispielsweise
sagen, also wenn man einen ordentlichen Switch hat oder einen ordentlichen Router, wobei man
braucht einen Switch, hat zu wenig Ports, kann man so Dinge machen wie, der Klein muss
sich erstmal alternifizieren, dass der Netzwerk-Port funktioniert oder die Mac-Adresse muss stimmen,
aber das ist Overkill, das macht eigentlich keiner daheim, oder hat jemand Port-Security
bei euch im Heimbereich, wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Sergeant Blackburn, beantworte ich alles noch heute, ich habe jetzt ja hier mein schönes
PP-Grad-Tool, wo alle Fragen drin gelockt sind, das heißt, ich vergesse auch nichts, genau,
das würde ich machen zuerst, Internet, Netzwerk, wichtig, okay weiter, als nächstes würde
ich ein WLAN, nennen wir es mal User WLAN, wie auch immer, das ist das normale WLAN,
was man so kennt, da kommen Tablets rein, da kommen Smartphones rein, da kommt vielleicht
der smarte Fernseher rein, falls man den da reinhängen will, wobei, da komme ich gleich
dazu, würde ich ihn hier unbedingt machen, übrigens, ich fange jetzt hier nicht an mit
WLANs oder sowas, ich malen mal nur, wie logisch von oben betrachtet die Trennung aussehen
würde, ob man die Dinge jetzt tatsächlich an den eigenen Port jeweils dran hängt, oder
ob man das über WLANs macht, das ist ja dann im Endeffekt ein bisschen, ist ja dann eigentlich
egal, so, das ist so das Basic Setup, was ich immer machen würde, ich würde das hier
nicht miteinander verbinden, ich würde immer sagen, es gibt ein safes, internes Netzwerk,
da kommen nur Ports dran, da kommen nur Kabel dran und es gibt ein halbwegs sicheres, normales
WLAN, da kommen auch keine, in dieses WLAN kommen auch keine Leute rein, den gibt man
auch keinen Leuten den Zugang, wo man, den man nicht traut, aber trotzdem, sollte man
mal irgendwie jemand den Zugang gegeben haben, oder was auch immer, derjenige hat schon mal
keinen Zugang auf meine internen sensiblen Sachen, weil Zugriff von hier nach hier ist
nicht, Zugriff von hier nach hier ist kein Problem und Zugriff von WLAN nach Internet
ist auch okay, dann, wenn man öfters Gäste hat, es gibt ja Leute, die sind so sozial
und haben manchmal Leute bei sich, also ich nicht, aber gibt's ja, dann würde ich noch
ein, nennen wir es mal Gäste-WLAN machen, bzw. man könnte auch schon sowas, ich nenne
es mal Gäste-WLAN, schräg, schräg, Internet of Things-WLAN, man kann sich dann überlegen,
ob man, ob man wirklich noch ein drittes machen möchte, also ich hab drei WLANs, drei WLANs
ist bei mir nicht drei unterschiedliche Access Points, sondern ein Access Points mit drei
WLAN-IDs und WLANs drunter, so, das würde ich machen und der ist schon ein bisschen
unsicherer, das Ganze, hier kann man den Zugang Gästen geben und hier kann man auch seine
ganzen IoT-Devices reinhängen, ich würde, ja, Sys0, du hast recht, ich würde es auch,
ich würde es auch nicht so machen, das machen wir aber in der Reihe nach jetzt, ich würde
es auch nicht so machen, aber wenn man, wenn man es nicht total übertreiben will, kann
man das so machen, ich würde allerdings IoT und Gäste auch trennen, wobei ich hab kein
Gäste-WLAN, weil ihr wisst ja, ich bin Keller-Admin, der hat keine Freunde, da kommen auch keine
Leute vorbei, dafür bin ich dieses Jahr erstaunlich braun, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt,
es ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen, ey, warum hab ich überhaupt Farbe, genau, also bei
mir ist das nicht so, aber wir nennen es mal Gäste-Gäste an IoT-WLAN, hier kann man
dann zum Beispiel die geflashte Steckdosenleiste reinhängen oder sowas, allerdings hab ich
es ein bisschen anders, ich hab ein, ich hab das WLAN und ich hab noch ein, weil ich
auch kein Gäste-WLAN hab, ich hab nen China-WLAN, da ist zum Beispiel alle möglichen China-Dinger
drin, die ich nicht flaschen kann und den ich nicht so ganz traue und das China-WLAN,
das kommt nirgendwo hin, China-WLAN darf nicht ins Internet, China-WLAN darf nicht ins User-WLAN
und China-WLAN darf schon gar nicht ins Internet-Netzwerk, Internet-Netzwerk darf ins China-WLAN, User-WLAN
darf auch ins China-WLAN, allerdings ansonsten nichts, so, wenn man das trennt, könnte man
auch sagen, Gäste-WLAN, China-WLAN, wir machen die WLANs mal ein bisschen kleiner, China-WLAN,
Gäste-WLAN, so ungefähr sieht das bei mir aus, ja und ich hab noch ein Test-WLAN offen,
wo ich immer mal wieder ein bisschen herumspiele, aber so könnte man das im Prinzip machen,
es sieht kompliziert aus, man braucht dafür gar nicht so viele Geräte, wenn man nämlich
sich ordentliche Geräte kauft, also ordentliche Access-Points bzw. ordentliche Router, kann
man das alles mit diesen Geräten machen, man braucht keine 3 Access-Points, oder sonst
was, man braucht einen ordentlichen Access-Point, der mehrere WLANs aufmachen kann, das ist
alles und der WLANs kann, so und wenn man per VPN drauf zugreifen will, dann würde ich
noch sowas hier machen, OpenVPN, OpenVPN ist auch ein eigenes Netz, das ist dann hier
irgendwie so dazwischen, da kann man sich überlegen, wo das hin darf, was man haben
will, ich hab 3 SSIDs, genau, richtig, so und der Zugriff ist folgendermaßen, das China-WLAN
ist übrigens rot, genauso rot wie das Internet, das darf nirgends wohin, oh das war orange,
ich meine es ist immerhin noch, ja das ist rot, was alles das hier gemeinsam hat ist,
es darf nicht in das interne Netzwerk, ich finde das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Regel,
sollte es irgendwie doch mal erforderlich sein, dass man ins interne Netzwerk muss,
zum Beispiel, weil man sich bei OpenVPN verbunden hat und auf das interne Nass zugreifen will,
da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, was man machen kann, man muss sich überlegen,
sind das so sensible Daten, dass die ins interne Netzwerk gehören, vielleicht hat man ja
irgendeine Kiste im WLAN, wo man, oder nicht im WLAN, also in diesem Netz drin, das muss
ja nicht zwangsläufig wirklich WLAN sein, nur weil das das WLAN Netz ist, dass man die
vielleicht da reinlegen kann und wenn man sagt, ok, man muss unbedingt von OpenVPN
auf das interne Netzwerk zugreifen, dann würde ich auf keinen Fall sagen, OpenVPN darf auf
das interne Netzwerk zugreifen, sondern ich würde genau diese eine Sache freischalten,
man kann da noch beliebige Hürden noch einbauen, man könnte noch irgendwie ein Reverseproxy
dazwischen stellen oder was auch immer, wo man sich noch mal identifizieren muss, allerdings
prinzipiell würde ich dann nur diese eine Sache freischalten, dann würde ich halt sagen,
ok, ich schalte frei von OpenVPN auf mein internes NAS, allerdings dann auch nur auf
dem einen Port, den ich für Datenshare brauche, wenn ich das wirklich haben will, so würde
ich das machen, so oder so ähnlich ist es bei mir daheim auch gemacht, ein VPN-Anbieter,
den ich ans Herz legen kann, ich benutze keine VPN-Anbieter, einziger VPN-Anbieter bin ich
selber zu, wenn ich mich daheim einwählen will, wo sitzt der Piehall, den du hast, den
habe ich gerade nicht, den habe ich nicht mehr, und wenn ich ihn hätte, würde der da sitzen,
nehme ich genau aus dem Grund, den ich gerade erklärt habe, der sitzt da, weil man kann
hier von drauf, man kann hier von drauf und man kann hier von drauf, würde der da stehen,
könnte ich aus dem Wlan nicht drauf, oder dann müsste es hier drüber irgendwie so proxien,
also der würde hier stehen, wenn ich einen hätte, ich habe aber keinen mehr, da bringt
mir leider nichts, weil Twitch kannst du nicht mehr blocken, YouTube kannst du nicht mehr
richtig blocken, und wenn man dadurch, dass man das China Wlan hat, kann man auch irgendwelche
komischen China Cloud Dinge aber sich daheim im Netzwerk betreiben, ohne dass man Angst
haben muss, dass die Dinge irgendwas treiben, weil in diesem Netzwerk, und es ist wichtig
Leute, denkt dran, wenn ihr so ein Netzwerk macht, und blockiert den Zugriff, dann blockiert
alles, ja, lasst am besten Deny Any standardmäßig drinnen für dieses Netz, also man sollte
ja seine Firewall eh so einstellen, dass die Fault-Regel ist alles verbieten, was nicht
erlaubt ist, umgedrehter Fall finde ich bisschen sinnlos, man kann natürlich eine Firewall
auch machen, okay, man verbietet es explizit, ansonsten ist es erlaubt, aber normalerweise
machst du das so, du verwirrst alles was nicht explizit erlaubt ist, und denkt dran,
ihr müsst wirklich darauf sorgen, das Ding darf nirgends wohin, das heißt das Ding darf
auch nicht ins Internet pingen oder so, und das China Ding darf auch kein DNS ins Internet
machen, das darf nichts, das darf in seinem eigenen Netzwerk rumgammeln, und was ihr dann
auch noch macht ist, ihr schaltet auf eurem, auf eurem, ähm, auf eurem Access Point, schaltet
nur noch Klein Isolation an, Isolation, Isolation, Isolation, das bedeutet, dass sogar in diesem
WLAN selbst die Geräte nicht mal miteinander reden dürfen, oh, und dann ist vorbei, ah,
die China Dinger keine Chance mehr, Frage beantwortet, ähm, wer hat das mit Netzwerk
eingefragt, seh ich jetzt nicht mehr, aber ich hoffe, Frage ist beantwortet, hallo Mavit49,
einfach keine China Dinger kaufen, ja, das ist keine Option, äh, smarte Lampen hab ich
beantwortet, Bild hab ich auch beantwortet, funktioniert's, was auch immer, ähm, ich
könnte mir das Bild mal speichern, das brauchen wir bestimmt öfters mal, Download, bam, ähm,
Roller an, hab ich auch beantwortet, ähm, ja und ne, ich muss erst überlegen, wie ich
das mache, und ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie viele Leute das auf YouTube interessiert,
wenn ich was über Heimautomatisierungen habe, wieso Chrome und Chromium, weil ich, ich hab
Chrome, Chromium, feierabend, ich hab so ziemlich alles drauf an Browser, was es gibt, aber
beantwortet, äh, Sartre Blackburn, bist noch da, er fragt nämlich Heimax, ich hab angefangen,
sie sharp zu lernen, weil ich, ähm, weil ich eine Ausbildung als Anwendungsentwickler
machen will, und die meisten Firmen schon wollen, dass man was kann, äh, da wäre ich
generell immer ein bisschen vorsichtig, so je nachdem, was das für ein Laden ist, natürlich
ist es schön, wenn der Azubi schon im Vorfeld was kann, was man aber nicht vergessen darf,
ich sag zum Rest gleich was, was man nicht vergessen darf, und ich sag nicht, dass du
es vergessen hast, aber was, was manche Firmen, glaub ich, ab und zu vergessen ist, die Ausbildung
dient dazu, nicht, dass man es vorher schon kann, und einfach ne billige Arbeitskraft
ist, sondern, die Ausbildung dient dazu, dass man das ordentlich lernt, und das wird manchmal
einfach vergessen, deswegen, ich find's gar nicht, ich find's auch bei uns gar nicht
so wild, wir haben in letzter Zeit wenig Azubis, das ist, ist so, aber, ähm, ich fänd's auch
cool, wenn wir wieder mehr hätten, vielleicht Ende des Jahres wieder, ähm, ja, ich find's
bei uns Azubis auch ganz cool, wenn die schon was können, aber das ist mir eigentlich
egal, mir ist es lieber, die interessieren sich generell dafür, als dass, äh, sie
der Ansicht sind, ey, ich, ich hab schon einige gesehen bei uns, so bei uns auch, die gesagt
haben, ja, ich mach jetzt die Ausbildung, aber eigentlich kann ich das alles schon,
und ich mach das ja nur, dass ich ne ordentlich abgeschlossene Ausbildung hab, aber ich kann
es ja eh schon, und meistens bei denen ist es so, dass die es nicht richtig können,
die fragst sie dann so ganz einfache Netzwerkgeschichten, zum Beispiel, ja, was passiert denn, wenn Rechner
A was zu Rechner B schickt, wie, wie ist dann so der Ablauf, dann haben die keine Ahnung,
wie es funktioniert.
Das hab ich mir fast schon gedacht, Patrick, das hab ich mir fast schon gedacht, mit was
hast du dann Smart Home realisiert, also als, äh, als Hub und Oberfläche hab ich Home Assistant
ein, ich hab kein, kein, nix, ich hab ne Mischung aus, äh, wie gesagt, Home Assistant ist der
Hub, ich hab ne Mischung aus SeaWave Netzwerk, ein paar Microcontroller, ein paar WLAN,
äh, Steckdosen, ein paar Custom, Custom Geschichten, wie beispielsweise dem Rollo, Roll, dem Roller,
Wickler, das, der halt die Rollos runter macht, ähm, ein bisschen altertümliche Funkgeschichten
für die anderen Rolläden, ähm, ja, das ist so ne Mischung aus allem, und das Schöne
daran ist auch einfach, dass es mit Home Assistant sich gut integrieren lässt.
So, ähm, äh, Baumi schreibt die Frage nochmal mit Adwoobloss, dass ich sie nicht vergesse,
weil, sonst überseh ich's, achso genau, ähm, aber ich komm nicht so richtig voran, weil
ich nicht weiß, wo ich anfangen soll, bzw. bräuchte ich zu jedem Thema Aufgaben, damit
ich es festigen kann, ich bin nicht so kreativ, das geht jedem so, ähm, beziehungsweise weiß
ich nicht, was ich alles machen kann, sodass ich mir selbst Aufgaben stellen könnte.
Mit was, mit was lernst du denn SeaSharp, hast du ein Buch, oder mit was lernst du das?
Was wurde aus dem Azubi, der nicht mal erkannt hat, der gut durchgekommen ist?
Ne, also ja, der hat's geschafft, aber einen guten Abschluss hat er nicht, nicht gerade
gemacht.
Mich hat aber letztens, doch, mich hat letztens mal wieder einer erkannt, letztes Jahr, einer
der neuen Anwendungsentwickler bei uns, der hat so gesagt, äh, bist du da Max?
Also, ja, wieso?
Ja, mir kommt deine Stimme bekannt vor, haha, ich hab gesagt, achso, wirklich, ja.
Also, der wusste Bescheid, als ich exposed.
Mit Videos, äh, ja, doch, Videos sind, Videos sind eine gute Quelle, um, um Sachen zu lernen,
was ich dir empfehlen würde, Sergeant Blackburn, ist, lest dir mal zumindest die ersten paar
Kapitel, bis es dann zu advancederen Themen kommt, ähm, nehm dir das mal, ich glaub,
das ist das letzte, nehm dir das mal, nehm dir mal, das ist zwar, das ist zwar von 2012,
allerdings die Basics haben sie nicht gern, ist kostenlos, und lest dir das mal durch,
bis Artikel, äh, bis, bis, ähm, bis inclusive 16, bis 16, lest dir das mal bis 16 durch,
dann weißt du schon ganz gut Bescheid, und ich finde, es ist einfacher, das in der Buchform
zu lernen, als, ähm, als so, ja, und auf die Frage hin, was du machen kannst, als,
als, als, als Aufgaben, ich kann dir eigentlich nur empfehlen, ne, bei diesen Standarddingern,
die jeder macht, so irgendwie mal, wir fangen, wir machen mal einen Body-Mass-Index-Rechner
und sowas, das sind so 10 Zeilen, das juckt eigentlich gar nicht, äh, ich kann dir eigentlich
nur empfehlen, überleg dir mal, irgendein Thema, was dich interessiert, zum Beispiel,
falls du einen Battlefield-Server hast, dass du eine Statistik-Seite für deinen Battlefield-Server
machst, mit C-Sharp im Backend, oder dass du, irgendwas, irgendwas, was dich interessiert,
so diese 0815 Übungsaufgaben sind meistens ziemlich kacke, und haben mit der Realität
auch nicht viel, nicht viel zu tun, weil, wenn du, wenn du halbwegs ordentliche Basics
drauf hast, also sprich, wenn du das Buch gelesen hast, bis Artikel, äh, bis, bis, ähm, Kapitel
16 oder 15, oder was das war, dann hast du die Basics drauf, wenn man die Basics halbwegs
ordentlich drauf hat, dann muss man's ein bisschen benutzen, dass man's lernt, und
während man's benutzt, stellt man dann auch fest, wie die Sachen miteinander funktionieren
und zusammenhängen, und vor allem das, was man noch nicht gecheckt hat. Also, das wünsch
dir empfehlen. So, ich hoffe, das hat die Frage beantwortet, ähm, irgendwas übersehen.
Irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob ich ordentliche Axis-Points hab, ich hoffe, das hat er mit
Adwoble ausgestellt, genau, also, das haben wir beantwortet, ich hoffe, hat gepasst,
hat dir was gebracht, ähm, wo würdest du die Firewall hinpacken, wo nimmst du einfach
den Paketfilter vom Mikrotik-Router, ja. Äh, brauch ich da heimlich, die Packet-Inspection
brauchen wir da heimlich, ALG weiß ich jetzt nicht mal aus dem Kopf, wofür's steht. Was
steht in ALG? Application, ah, okay, ähm, Application Layer Gateway, also, quasi, ähm,
Layer 7, äh, Filter. Das kann, das, also, ein bisschen Layer 4 Plus kann der Mikrotik
auch. Also, der Mikrotik kann zum Beispiel, äh, ein bisschen HTTP verstehen und sowas,
allerdings ist das nicht so wahnsinnig schnell und schön. Und die Packet-Inspection brauch
ich nicht, daheim brauch ich das nicht. Ich würd, ich würd erst mal am Anfang den
Paketfilter und die Firewall vom Mikrotik-Router verwenden. Okay, ähm, du sitzt der Bahnnehmer
am Fenster, ne, eigentlich nicht. Welchen Access Point bist du? Okay, da kommen wir jetzt
zum Thema Access Points. Ähm, hat nämlich hier oben auch schon der MaxElectronics gefragt,
kannst du auch eventuell einen WLAN Access Point empfehlen, am besten einen, der sich
gut verlängern lässt, eventuell auch eine Version für draußen hat. Ähm, da gibts
eigentlich zwei Sachen. Für Outdoor, äh, irgendwie hat mein Herz gerade rumgespackt.
Also, du könntest entweder die Schiene gehen, du könntest dir die Mikrotik Sachen mal angucken.
Allerdings finde ich, sind die Mikrotik Sachen ein bisschen nicht so zeitgemäß. Die haben
ganz viele WLAN Geschichten, also vor allem die günstigen WLAN Geschichten bei Mikrotik,
können plus 2,4 Gigahertz, das ist quasi noch das alte. Sie haben zwar mittlerweile
auch schon vermehrt Sachen mit 5 Gigahertz, allerdings, so die Einsteiger-Sachen sind
alle noch 2,4 Gigahertz, also quasi Mikrowelle, also, nein, der gleichen Frequenz wie eure
Mikrowelle, äh, sind keine Mikrowelle, ähm, und das ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen altertüblich
finde ich, ja. Ansonsten bin ich eigentlich ein Fan von Mikrotik Sachen, allerdings,
im WLAN Bereich hält sichs in Grenzen. Ähm, wo man eigentlich nichts falsch machen kann,
sind die Ubiquiti-Dinger. Also mein Netzwerkequipment setzt sich eigentlich so geteilt aus Ubiquiti
und Mikrotik zusammen. Ich wollte ja noch, ich habs in einem der letzten Lives, ich habs
ja erzählt, dass ich eigentlich die Ubiquiti-Dinger wieder weg haben will, weil es mir auf den
Keks geht, dass die kein ordentliches Webinterface haben, dass man diesen komischen UniFi-Controller
für haben will. Allerdings finde ich sie jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet doch, ähm,
fürs WLAN besser. Also rein vom WLAN her, äh, wie die Mikrotik-Dinger. So, und wenn
du dir zum Beispiel, die haben jetzt auch einen neuen, da kann ich allerdings nicht
viel dazu sagen, ich habs so ein, ich habs so ein, aber die haben jetzt auch einen neuen,
da musst du mal gucken. Ähm, musst mal gucken, die haben jetzt, die haben jetzt einen neuen,
die haben jetzt einen neuen WLAN und Ubiquiti hat ziemlich sicher auch Outdoor-WLANs. Ähm,
der ist auf jeden Fall gut, mit dem kannst du auf jeden Fall nichts falsch machen, das
ist eines der besten Access Points, die du dir holen kannst. Ähm, du brauchst allerdings,
um die Sachen zu managen, den UniFi-Server, kannst du aber auf einem Raspberry laufen
lassen oder auf irgendeinem x-beliebigen anderen Rechner, den du so hast. Oder du kannst im
ganz, wenn du das ganz hardcore machen willst, kannst du auch von deinem Smartphone die Dinger
dienen, geht auch. Nur ein ordentliches Webinterface zum managen haben sie leider nicht, das ist
das was mich da ein bisschen nervt. Ähm, aber das ist gut, also die sind richtig gut und
ich geh mal davon aus, die haben auch Outdoor-Varianten davon. Aber mit dem hier kannst du definitiv
nichts falsch machen, das ist eines der besten Access Points, ähm, für den privaten Bereich,
der auch erschwinglich ist, den man sich holen kann. Ne, ne, ne, ne, du brauchst keinen alten
Dell-Server hinstellen, das ist total Overkill dafür. Dann hol dir lieber einen Raspberry
Pi Zero, reicht auch dicke aus. Ähm, ja Nico, das ist die nächste Variante, du könntest
auch dir selbst OpenWrt drauf installieren auf irgendeinem Access Point, wenn du mehr
Optionen brauchst, aber, hiermit kannst du wenig falsch machen. Du musst nur mal gucken,
was, ich hab letztens gelesen, die haben was neues, was ähnlich gut ist, ein bisschen
günstiger und irgendwie paar neuere Features hat. Keine Ahnung, aber ich bin hier mit beschäftigt,
aber da macht man eigentlich nichts mit verkehrt. Okay, ähm, ja, genau, ich hab auch diesen
Access Point. Das haben wir, haben wir, hast du deine Klimaanlage geflasht? Klar. Chrome
und Chromium haben wir auch beantwortet, VPN-Anbieter. Wann guckst du eigentlich mal, sie scharpt
zum Kuseln im Stream? Wollte ich das? Könnten wir echt mal machen. Merke ich mir mal, schreib
ich mir mal auf, Stream to do, sie scharpt zum Kuseln. Ich wollte auch meine Vita flaschen
im Stream mal. Da weiß ich aber nicht, ob das Monkathos ist, wenn ich die Vita flasche
im Stream. Ubuntu Server bringt Nextcloud als Snap mit, spricht was dagegen, die Nextcloud
instant als Snap laufen zu lassen oder sollte ich eine konventionelle Installation setzen?
Sprich, also ich wüsste nicht, was dagegen spricht, das als Snap laufen zu lassen. Es
spricht, finde ich, generell bei Nextcloud ein bisschen was dagegen. Ich weiß allerdings
nicht, wie das mit dem Snap ist, sie in einem Container laufen zu lassen bzw. in einem
Container, der quasi nicht auf eigenes Betriebssystem macht, so wie LXD oder LXC. Die haben beispielsweise
bei ihrem Docker-Image hatten die jahrelang Probleme bei Nextcloud-Updates, das hat nicht
richtig funktioniert. Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit dem Snap ist. Und ich weiß auch nicht,
wie das mit dem aktuellen, offiziellen Docker-Container ist. Ich habe meine Nextcloud in der Regel
als LXD-Container laufen, das ist quasi bis auf den Kern ein eigenes Betriebssystem,
was Filesystem angeht. Da kann man nicht viel falsch machen eigentlich dann. Aber ansonsten,
wenn das funktioniert, spricht Wapmix dagegen, das als Snap laufen zu lassen. Achso, das
war die Frage vom Baumi. Ach, jetzt sehe ich es erst. Ja, der Patrick hat das gefragt.
Also ich bin auch Schüler und habe mir das Programm selber beigebracht. Nice. Sehr,
sehr, Moment. Warte mal, es ist noch praktisch. Ich hoffe aber, es war wenigstens. Aber bislang
nur Software. Ich kann die Websites von Backends bauen, aber habe nicht so viel Ahnung von
Microcontroller oder generell Netzwerk. Ja gut, Microcontroller ist auch ein Thema,
da bin ich jetzt auch nicht gerade so der Ultra-Pro drin. Nur weil man ein bisschen ESP32 und
Arduino programmieren kann, ist man also nicht so der Microcontroller-Owner. Ich würde es
halt machen, wenn ich ein Projekt hätte im Endeffekt, was das braucht. Und deswegen
finde ich deine Streams so geil. Das ist auch sehr nice zu, weil du dich halt anscheinend
verdammt gut auskennst. Ah ja, ich habe einfach schon ein bisschen Erfahrung. Umso besser
man sich auskennt, umso mehr stellt man eigentlich fest, von wie vielen Sachen man eigentlich
überhaupt keine Ahnung hat. RIP deine Frage. Habe ich die gelöscht einfach so oder hast
du sie nicht mit nvpl ausgestellt? Nee, vpn habe ich doch beantwortet, dass ich kein vpn-Anbieter
verwende, dass ich mein eigener vpn-Anbieter bin für daheim. Ich verwende kein vpn-Anbieter,
um irgendwie netflix auszudrücken, äh auszudricksen oder sonst was. Nee, Hexer hast nichts verpasst.
Ich verwende kein vpn-Anbieter. Das einzige vpn, was ich verwende, und das habe ich auch
gerade aktuell nicht an, ist wenn ich von außen auf mein heim, also bei mir daheim zugreifen
will. Ich würde gerne versuchen ein Programm zu schreiben, das per ssh auf einen Router-Switch
geht und bestimmte Parameter rausschreibt. Was für eine Sprache würdest du empfehlen?
Gar keine, ich würde mir mehr SNMP angucken. Wenn es unbedingt sein muss per ssh, dann
würde ich es über ein Shell-Skript machen. Das ist total easy im Shell-Skript, sich einloggen
und Kommandos ausführen, ssh. Und wenn es unbedingt eine Sprache sein soll, ist die Frage,
auf welches Betriebssystem du es laufen lassen willst. Wenn du es auf Linux laufen lassen
willst, dann eindeutig ein Shell-Skript, da brauchst du nicht viel, ssh, user-add, anführungszeichen,
befehl und gib ihm. Wenn du es aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht in einem Shell-Skript machen
willst, dann, unter Linux ist, dann kannst du es mit allem möglichen machen, ruby, pys und
sonst was. Ich würde da irgendwie schnell einen Skript zusammenwursten. Und wenn du
es wirklich in einer etwas advancederen Geschichte machen willst, dann kannst du auch mit C-Sharp
in.NET Core machen und SSH Library verwenden, du kannst es auch in Go machen, vielleicht
vollkommen egal, wobei prinzipiell würde ich mir erstmal angucken SNMP, weil SNMP ist
genau für sowas da. Das wurde dafür quasi erfunden, um Sachen vor Netzwerkgeräten abfragen
zu können. Kannst du es auch in Assembly machen? Ja, also ich würde sagen, der Clocks HD programmiert
uns bis zum nächsten Stream in ssh-agent in Assembler. Allerdings, bitteschön, in Assembler,
in diesem ESP32-ULP-Assembler, der nur 8 Befehle hat. Wusste ich, dass es für dich kein Problem
ist. Ja, Martin beantwortet. Gibt es auch eine Firewall gegen der R8 der Computer ausschalten
oder Kneifzange? Kneifzange ist da eigentlich immer am besten dafür geeignet. Ja, der Horx
hat Recht, wenn man die Basics ein bisschen gecheckt hat, wenn man ein Buch gelesen hat,
muss man sich einfach ein paar Sachen überlegen, die man machen will. Er schreibt ja auch hier,
als versuchen wir mit der Seite und danach selbst Sachen programmieren, die mir Spaß
machen. Ja, am besten ist natürlich, wenn du noch irgendwas findest, was dich nicht
nur interessiert, sondern was dann auch, wenn es fertig ist, irgendwas bringt. Ja, bei
mir ist es aktuell viel im Zusammenhang mit meiner Heimautomatisierung, wo ich machen
muss. Zum Beispiel habe ich mir was gebastelt, was bei, das ist übrigens auch was Schönes,
was bei DPD, DHL, UPS und Amazon Logistics abfragt, ob gerade Pakete bei mir auf dem
Weg sind. Für C-Sharp gibt es auch eine schöne Twitch-Library. Echt, welche denn? Das war
gar nicht so einfach. Da wird ein bisschen rumgetrickst. Ich nehme so eine allgemeine
Tracking-Seite und wenn das irgendwie gerade rumbackt, versuche ich direkt abzurufen von
Amazon und so. Das ist auch sowas. Das bringt dann auch was, wenn es fertig ist. Nach sowas
würde ich gucken. Oder einfach Sachen, die einen halt interessieren. Ist immer schwierig,
um jetzt konkrete Beispiele zu sagen. Irgendwas, was zu dem passt, was du sonst machst. Ansonsten,
wenn dir gar nichts einfällt, kannst du ja im nächsten Stream nochmal schreiben, dass
dir nichts eingefallen ist, dann denken wir uns irgendwas aus. Alle samt, ja. So, ähm,
aktuelle Serie auf YouTube und Twitch, in der ein 8-Bit-PC von Grund aufgebaut wird.
Ja, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, klar. Hast dein oder das nächste verpasst. Kann
der ESP866 irgendeine Verschlüsselung, oder ist er so klein, so langsam? Doch, du kannst,
also der ESP866 kann natürlich alle möglichen Verschlüsselungen aus Libraries für gibt
oder die du selbst machst. Also potenziell alle. Aber halt nicht so wahnsinnig schnell.
Was kein Problem ist, ist SSL zum Beispiel. Das habe ich schon eingebaut. Dann nimmst
du anstatt dem Wi-Fi Client einfach den Wi-Fi Client Secure und schon kannst du ohne Probleme
SSL, HTTPS, TLS Verbindungen aufbauen. Das funktioniert, ist kein Problem. Das schnellste
ist es in der Tat nicht. Allerdings, in der Standard-Library ist, glaube ich, also zumindest
bei Arduino, ist sogar schon, ähm, so die üblichen verdächtigen IES, RSA und SHA-256
mit drinnen. Nicht, nicht ultra schnell, aber für die kleinen Datenmengen, die so ein ESP3266
überträgt, kein Ding. Selbst gemacht habe ich noch nicht, ähm, außer SSL-Verbindung.
Tja, damit habe ich ja schon gemacht. Allerdings habe ich schon mit dem ESP32 gemacht und im
Prinzip wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so ein großer Unterschied sein dazwischen. Ein Unterschied
ist, doch es gibt einen großen Unterschied dazwischen zwischen ESP32 und ESP866, nämlich
dass der ESP32 Hardware IES drauf hat und ich glaube der ESP866 nicht. So, ist beantwortet.
Würdest du OpenVPN und Router trennen, also vom Gerät her? Nö. Nö. Würde ich nicht
machen. Kann man machen, würde ich aber so pauschal nicht machen. Und liegt zum größten,
es ist ja immer so eine Sache, die man abwägen muss, ja. Generell ist dieses ganze Security-Thema
immer eine permanente Abwägung zwischen, wie einfach soll es im Handling sein und wie
sicher soll es sein. In der Regel sind umso sicherer die Sachen sind, umso komplizierter
sind sie zu handeln. Sowohl für den User als auch für den Admin. Oder auch für den
Programmierer. Für alle. Ähm, in dem Fall traue ich MikroTik eigentlich zu, dass sie
in der Lage sind so ein Standardding wie OpenVPN in ordentlicher Qualität anzubieten und ich
mir keinen eigenen Raspberry oder irgendwas hinstellen muss als OpenVPN Gateway. Würde
ich nicht machen. Ich würde das OpenVPN auf dem MikroTik oder auf dem Router betreiben.
Oh fuck. Hab grad, hab grad ein bisschen Johannesbeeren gefordert. Hab grad einen Stil mitgefordert.
Mankergrün, äh, Mankersmoke. Ok, grünes Zeug vom Busch im Garten schmeckt nicht gut.
OpenVPN auf dem MikroTik. Nö, hab ich nicht. Warum ist die so schlecht? Weshalb ist die
so schlecht? Nutzt du lieber Discord oder aktuell Discord? Discord Beste. Echt, ist
das so? Ok. Ich hab noch kein OpenVPN über MikroTik gemacht. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
nicht gedacht, dass das so scheiße ist. Gibt es, gibt es Dings hier, ähm, wie ist das?
Oh, WireGuard ist das neue, ne? Oder neue, neue Shit. Gibt es das für MikroTik eigentlich?
Ähm, TomTastic, ich kann dazu überhaupt nichts sagen. Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich wollte schon mal eine ganze Weile ausprobieren. Ok, gibt's anscheinend noch nicht.
Also sollte OpenVPN wirklich so scheiße auf dem MikroTik sein, kann man sich sehr überlegen,
ob man ein eigenes Geld hinstellt. Wobei ich jetzt eigentlich davon ausgegangen wäre, dass
das ganz ok ist. Ich schrei, ich schreibe mir das mal bei meinem, bei meinem Stream Ideen
to do's auf, dass wir mal WireGuard ausprobieren können. Vielleicht auch ein Raspberry oder
so. Ok, ähm, ja, da hab ich jetzt was zu gesagt. Also wie gesagt, sollte das wirklich so kacke
sein, dass OpenVPN auf dem MikroTik rutscht. Dann muss man sich wirklich was anderes überlegen,
aber ich kann's weder bestätigen noch widerlegen irgendwie. Ok, das ist natürlich ein ziemlicher
Mist. So, ähm, welches Linux empfählst du für daily? Kommt drauf an, was du für eine,
was du für Linux Kenntnisse hast. Also wenn du dich schon ganz gut auskennst, oder zumindest
die Basics kennst, ich bin ja Verfechter von, äh, von Manjaro mit I3. Oder generell Manjaro.
Manjaro Beste. Waller. Ähm, ich hab irgendwie das falsche Profil eingestellt, ne? Bull.
Und sagen, warum sieht meine Konsole so kacke aus? Ja, das hier ist auch Manjaro mit I3,
das verwende ich auch auf der Arbeit. Ähm, ist für mich die beste Distribution für Desktop-Systeme,
wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt. Gefällt mir persönlich einfach am besten. I3 ist ein
bisschen Rise of Milch-Rice, das ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, I3. I3 hat halt keine
Fenster, ne? Ähm, also man kann, man kann natürlich auch Fenster machen, wenn man Fenster
will, aber normalerweise will man keine Fenster. Für Windows-Benutzer, beziehungsweise für
Gnome, KDE, XFCE, LXDE, was es da nicht alles gibt, Benutzer, ist I3 ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig,
weil die halt gewöhnt sind Fenster zu verwenden. Allerdings bin ich der Meinung, ähm, in
der Regel will man sowas wie Fenster gar nicht haben, weil I3 ist die Philosophie halt
alles Fullscreen. So, das heißt, wenn ich, ich mach das jetzt hier mal zu, das heißt,
wenn ich nicht aufzahm, wenn ich nichts offen hab, ist der jeweilige Desktop einfach leer,
außer ein Hintergrundbild. Es gibt ja auch keine Desktop-Icons oder sonst was, was ja
ganz logisch ist, weil ich meine, es gibt kein Fenster, was das davor, was man davor
machen kann. Ich glaube, man kann mit ein bisschen Trick 17 ein Desktop mit Icons machen,
aber das ist komplett sinnlos, weil du hast eh mal ein Fenster davor. So, wenn man an
etwas startet, das erste, was passiert, sobald man es startet, geht Fullscreen, äh, geht
Fullscreen der Browser auf. Sobald du eine Anwendung startest, in dem Fall der Browser,
geht die immer Fullscreen auf. Ähm, startet man eine zweite Anwendung, teilen sie sich
den Bildschirm. Startet man eine dritte Anwendung, teilen sie sich den Bildschirm. Man kann natürlich
da noch einstellen, wie das platziert sein soll, ja. Also man kann sagen, hier unten
hätte man gerne sowas, hier oben hätte man gerne sowas und, und da hätten wir eine Browser.
Natürlich kann man die auch noch unterschiedlich irgendwie verschieben, wie man's gerne hätte,
aber das ist die Philosophie von E3. Ja, man kann Fenster machen, aber normalerweise macht
man eigentlich keine Fenster. Man kann das Ganze auch stacken, dass man hier oben so
Tabs hat, innerhalb von einem Desktop, ähm, aber man ist eigentlich null mit Fenstermanagement
beschäftigt und das ist das, was ich daran gut finde, weil man hat keine Fenster. Äh,
wie kann man bei E3 Scaling machen, wenn man eine High DPI hat? Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab kein High DPI. Ähm, ich geh mal davon aus, wenn's GTK ist, kann man irgendwie so
nen Scale Faktor angeben, wobei man halt sagen muss, High DPI und, und ordentliches Scaling
ist unter Linux eh noch nicht sooo das wahre. Was die hier dazu schreiben? Das ist von 2016.
Ähm, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung. Oh, es gibt einen Arsch Eintrag für High DPI. Irgendwelche
X Server Hacks. Ich glaub, da muss man einfach ein bisschen rumprobieren. Es ist unter Linux
eh noch nicht sooo toll mit High DPI und 4K Displays. So, haben wir beantwortet. Shell
Commands Over Fork, ja, das war irgendwas zu was anderem vorhin. Was hältst du generell
vom Studium bei einem, bei dem Softwareentwicklungssegment? Hä? Ich weiß nur, dass man viel Java lernt
in der Uni oder generell im Studium lernt man, lernt man relativ viel Java wahrscheinlich,
weil da alle Java können und denken, Java Beste, Alter. Beste, ja. Aber ich bin, ihr
kennt mich ja, ich bin nicht der Ansicht, dass Java Beste ist. Ich mag Java nicht. Ich
hab gegen die Java VM nichts, aber ich mag Java nicht. Wie switchst du zwischen Windows
und Linux mit, ähm, Steuerung, Windows, Taste, Pfeil nach rechts und Steuerung, Windows,
Taste, Pfeil nach links. Pfeil rechts, Pfeil links, Pfeil rechts, Pfeil links. Ja, mehr
durchdrehen, please. Pepega Board. Das Pepega Board hat sich jetzt schon ausgezahlt. So
viele Fragen, wie man heute durchkriegen, wo ich nix vergesse, haben wir selten gehabt.
Hatten wir. Welchen Router benutzt du privat? Also ich hab, ähm, einmal natürlich von
Unity Media das Ding, was dabei war. Ich hab ne, ne, die billigste Fritzbox überhaupt
bei der Telekom vorne dran und dahinter hab ich ein Mikrotik, äh, Hex PoE. Dann hab
ich vorne an der Klingel noch nen mini Mikrotik Access Point. Einfach einer, der über PoE
geht. Und an Switchen hab ich nen Ubiquiti ES16XG. Das ist ein 10G Switch mit 12 FSP
Plus Ports und 4 10G Kupfer Ports. Dann hab ich noch nen Mikrotik, 4 Ports, 10G Switch
und, äh, billig TP Link Ding. So, das dürfte jetzt alles gewesen sein. Ach ja und, äh,
Access Points ist Ubiquiti Access Points. Hatten wir schon? Hatten wir auch schon?
Welche, äh, äh, Alter, ich hätt das Johannis bei solchen essen sollen. Ähm, welche Skript
Sprache würdest du für einen Anfänger mit Linux empfehlen? Bash. Bash ist das universellste,
was du immer gebrauchen kannst. Das, im Vergleich zu PyS und Ruby, hast du halt das schöne,
wenn du bisschen Bash kannst, wirst du generell im Bedienen von der Kommandozeile auch besser.
Das erste, was ich lernen würde, wenn ich irgendwas skripten will unter Linux, ist Bash.
Bash ist nicht die schönste Sprache. Bash ist auch sicherlich nicht die schnellste Sprache
und auch nicht die konsistenteste Sprache. Allerdings ist Bash zum Einstieg und generell
für Linux Handling an sich das Beste, was man lernen kann. Bash. Ja, danach hätt ich
früher gesagt, Ruby, und ich mach immer noch viel mit Ruby, allerdings hat PyS generell
Ruby so ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen. Nicht nur im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld allgemein.
Neues Ruby Zeug gibt's heut kaum noch. PyS ist aber, glaub ich, wenn man auf GitHub guckt
oder generell bei Umfragen, die Sprache mit dem meisten Hype, den meisten neuen Projekten,
den meisten neuen geschriebenen Zeilen, dem meisten, also PyS ist ganz, ganz vorne aktuell.
Ruby ist auf dem absteigenden Ast. Leider. Wobei ich Ruby mach. Würdest du einen höheren
Abschluss als mittlere Reife für die Ausbilder? Das ist vollkommen egal. Es ist vollkommen
egal. Also es ist nur dann nicht egal, wenn derjenige, der Leute sucht, denkt, dass es
wichtig ist. Für die Ausbildung an sich ist es faktisch, also für mich steht das fest,
ist es egal, was du für einen Abschluss hast. Solange du genommen wirst, ja, geht's dir
ja grad rum. Aber für die Ausbildung bringt's dir nix. Ich hab auch noch mittlere Reife
gemacht. Ist allerdings schon ein bisschen näher. Ich hab auch ursprünglich nur mittlere
Reife gemacht. Und wenn du was kriegst, was geht, ja, vor allem in Regionen, wo halt viel
Technik ist, zum Beispiel Frankfurt, Köln wahrscheinlich auch, aber Frankfurt insbesondere,
da ist ja wo du hinspuckst irgendein Rechenzentrum in irgendeiner Ecke, da findest du auf jeden
Fall was. Und in der Ausbildung selbst profitierst du nicht wirklich davon. Die Ausbildung, also
die Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung ist scheiß einfach. Sagen wir's genau. Wir sagen es
mal wie es ist. Ist wirklich einfach. Das schafft jeder. Die IHK-Abschlussprüfung und
auch die Berufsschule, das ist wirklich einfach. Berufsschule ist absolut easy as fuck. Und
die IHK-Abschlussprüfung hat mit dem, was man im beruflichen Umfeld macht, eh nix zu
tun. Da geht's darum, dass man sich über Prüfungen vorher durchgelesen hat. Das war's.
Also die Ausbildung ist echt nicht schwer. Einzige Fenster des Winners Explorer, okay.
Hatten wir. Hatten wir. Ja, hatten wir. Ist das Dualboot? Das ist eine VM. Das ist eine
VM. Kommt ganz auf die Uni an. Jaja, klar, dachte ich mir auch. Wirst du eventuell vom
Hex auf die 19 Zoll Variante wechseln? Ach, soll da was Neues kommen? Der Hex hat einen
Switch drin. Allerdings hat der Hex bloß 5 Ports. Das ist halt jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Was für eine VM nutzt du? Das ist VM bei Workstation. Cheat, was meinst du denn auf
welche Variante, ob ich auf was für eine Variante wechseln will? Also ich hatte jetzt
eigentlich nicht vor, was zu wechseln. Das einzige, was ich abschaffen wollte, ist mein
Ubiquiti 10G-Switch. Den brauch ich nicht. Der ist komplett overkill. Komplett. Ja, Cheat,
das hab ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht noch einen Mikrotik-Switch kaufe. Einen ganz
einfachen Mikrotik-Gigabit-Switch mit irgendwie 20 Ports, 24 Ports oder so. Das hatte ich mir
überlegt. Die Sache ist die, dass die meisten günstigen Switche von Mikrotik oder die heißen
ja die CRS-Dinger, von denen die Router-Switche, die sie da haben, dass die nicht die besten
Router zum Routen-Routen sind. Die haben meistens eine schlechtere CPU drin als der Hex. Das
sind eigentlich eher Switche, die einen Router-OS drauf haben, was theoretisch Layer 3 und
Layer 4 ein bisschen kann, aber das ist nicht sonderlich gut. Die haben zum Beispiel auch
keine Hardware-Encryption-Dinger drauf, was heißt, dass man schon mal VPN ziemlich vergessen
kann, wenn man ein bisschen Wandbreite drüber haben will. Also wahrscheinlich nicht. Welche
Geräte ich an PoE habe, nur diesen Mini-Mikrotik-Access-Point, der vorne bei mir in der Klingel eingebaut ist.
Der ist 48 Volt PoE. Ja, das liegt einfach daran, weil ich nicht so viele Adern hatte,
die durch die Dienerwand noch frei waren. Für euch wird sehr viel C++-Java gemacht an
der Uni, das ist doch nice. Generell würde ich sagen, es ist eigentlich gar nicht mal
so wichtig, mit welcher Programmiersprache man anfängt. Ich persönlich mag Java nicht,
ich finde auch, dass C und C++ noch weniger, dass C++ wirklich keine gute Sprache ist zum
Einsteigen. Das Problem an C++ ist, dass C++ einfach 30 Jahre wildeste Syntax mit sich
rumschleppt und ganz viel davon sagen die C++-Leute, heute soll man gar nicht mehr verwenden.
Es geht noch, es ist teilweise wichtig, dass es da ist, weil es quasi in C so gemacht wird.
Ich finde C++ ist an sich keine schöne Sprache. Ich meine C++, ich kenne kaum eine Sprache,
noch nicht mal Erlang oder sowas besteht aus so vielen komischen verschiedenen Klammern
und Erlang ist nur Klammern, dafür Runde Klammern. C++ ist wir, was die Syntax angeht
und was man machen soll und was nicht und dürfen tut man ja theoretisch alles unter
C++, aber manche soll man nicht machen und ich finde es zum Einstieg keine schöne Sprache.
Xfanatics sagt, wenn man doch jedoch mit C++ anfängt, fallen alle anderen leichter und
man hat ein besseres Verständnis davon, was so vor sich geht. Das sehe ich anders, ich
denke die meisten Leute, die mit C++ anfangen, werden davon komplett versaut. Entweder
sorgt es dafür, dass sie nie wieder Bock haben zu programmieren, was verständlich
wäre oder dass sie eigentlich gar keine Ahnung haben, wie man das ordentlich macht.
C++ neigt dazu, dass man so lang rumbastelt, bis es geht und wenn es nicht geht, wird es
einfach zu Voidpointer gecastet. Also ich finde nicht, dass man mit C++ Vorteile hat,
wenn man damit anfängt. Du wirst als Einsteiger C++ nie auf ein gutes Level kriegen, weil
dir einfach viel zu viele Kenntnisse drum herum fehlen, warum man manche Sachen so machen
sollte oder manche Sachen ebenso nicht. Allein schon, wenn man sich überlegt, in C castest
du einfach. In C schreibst du einfach einen Pointer hin. Nicht so in C++. In C++ hast
du StaticCast, Autocast, ReinterpretCast, KunstCast, ne Autocast hast du nicht, Schwachsinn,
was auch immer. Dann den normalen C cast hast du noch. Dann hast du den Raw, deine Raw
Pointer, dann hast du den Adressoperator, den gibt es ja auch noch, wo manchmal halt
ganz klar ist, wann, wie, wo was verändert wird. Dann hast du Autopointer, Unicpointer,
Sharedpointer. Ich sage gegen die Konzepte nichts. Die sind an sich nicht verkehrt, aber
es ist einfach ein bisschen, das zu erfassen, ist einfach ein bisschen eine ziemlich hohe
Hürde. Dann gibt es so Sachen wie Autopointer, was man nicht mal verwenden soll. Ja.
Na ja. Gibt auch noch Konst und ey, es gibt in C++ ganz merkwürdige Sachen, ja. Dann
hast du irgendwie diese R-Value-Geschichte, Weakpointer. Es gibt ja in C++ irgendwie
sowas noch, Konst und und. Und dann kann man irgendwie da eine Lambda draus machen,
er captchert dann noch irgendwas. Und, ach, da hast du nicht gesehen. Und dann kannst
du doch sowas hier machen. Reference auf blup, das da und dann hier. Das ist gültig
in C++-Suntax irgendwie. Der Lambda, gegen den Lambda-Suntax kann man nichts sagen, wobei
doch gegen die Lambda-Suntax kann man was sagen, ich finde die Lambda C++-Suntax hässlich.
Also irgendwie ist es merkwürdig. Es mag vielleicht doch daran liegen, dass ich nicht
der allergrößte C++-Kennner bin oder auch nicht der allergrößte C++-Fan. Allerdings
denke ich zum Einstieg ist C++ nichts, nichts. Ich finde Lambdas an sich nicht schlecht,
ich mag das und habe überhaupt keine Probleme mit Lambdas. Unter JavaScript ist es sogar
schön, dass es das mittlerweile gibt. Ich meine, was hat die denn bei C++ wieder geritten,
dass man dafür jetzt irgendwie eckige Klammer nimmt. Ich habe das Gefühl, manche C++-Suntax
Sachen entstehen so, dass sie da in ihrem Gremium sitzen und sagen, hey, welches Zeichen
hat dann die wenigsten doppeldeutigen Bedeutungen zur Zeit in C++ und sagt dann irgend einer
und oder eckige Klammer und dann sagen sie, ja, dann lasst ihr einen neuen Operator mit
und und eckiger Klammer machen. So kommt mir das teilweise vor. Boah, mein Browser ist
gerade abgekackt, ich sehe nichts mehr auf dem zweiten Bildschirm. Also ich habe gerade
keine Vorschau mehr auf dem zweiten Bildschirm. Okay, es geht wieder, warum auch immer, was
auch immer das gewesen ist. Ja, genau, warum man unbedingt, warum man da unbedingt diesen
komischen, ich meine, ehrlich, ich kenne keine anderen Sprachen, wo man diesen Operator
überhaupt, vorbei, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ich sage das jetzt einfach
mal, wo man, wo man den Shift-Operator überhaupt überschreiben kann. Kann man das in C Sharp
machen? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob man das in C Sharp überschreiben kann. Okay, man kann
das, man kann das in C Sharp auch überschreiben. Na gut. Aber ich habe noch nie, und ich verwende
das ja schon ein paar Jahre, ich habe noch nie den Shift-Operator überschrieben, noch
nie. Ich wüsste gar nicht, wozu. Okay, wenn du irgendwelchen Low-Level-Int-Matte-Stells
vielleicht machst, ja, mit irgendwelchen eigenen Typen. Aber normalerweise, warum muss
man den Shift-Operator überschreiben? Mir fällt dazu überhaupt nichts. Warum? Und vor
allem, jede andere Geschichte, jede ordentliche andere Funktion wird einfach als Funktion
mit Klammern aufgerufen, aber nicht so C-Out in C++. Es hat einfach so viele Fallstricke,
dass ich nicht denke, dass es eine schöne Einstiegssprache ist. So, also was da war
jetzt? YouTuber mit 2000 Subs in 2019 ohne Gaming-Wähler. Mittlerweile gibt es alles.
Kennt ihr noch den Lackbuster? Das war doch auch so ein komisches Gerät, was angeblich
die Online-Games verbessern sollte. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Gibt es noch? Lackbuster. Tatsächlich gibt es noch. Oh. Geh weg. Geh weg. Skamars-Seite
war das. Vielleicht mal nachgucken. Warum ist mein Bildschirm schwarz? Ist bei euch
auch der... auch die Vorschau schwarz vom Bildschirm? Nee, oder? Ich glaube, das liegt
einfach an meinem Browser. Oh, ne. Okay, passt. Okay, ich habe neu geladen. Jetzt funktioniert
es. Weiß ich immer. Ich habe so einen Tick. Also neben dem Copy und Paste. Immer, wenn
ich eine Seite aufgemacht habe, die Skamars ist, dann mache ich den Prozess-Explorer auf
und gucke danach, ob irgendwie der China-Virus läuft im Hintergrund. Was eigentlich totaler
Schwachsinn ist mit dem Chrome und dem aktivierten... Ach so, Moment. Es hat ja bei euch wieder
den Bildschirm jetzt. So. Gucke ich immer nach. Oh, ist der China-Virus am Laufen? Da
stelle ich fest, ein Außer-die-scripted-Sendbox-64 ist am Laufen. Das ist, glaube ich, irgendein
Visual Studio-Ding, oder? Ob der China-Virus am Laufen ist, stelle ich fest, der China-Virus
ist nicht am Laufen. Das Schöne ist, wenn man hier Dings hat, Uplog Origin, man ist
eigentlich relativ safe auf den meisten Seiten. Es gibt keinen Lackbuster mehr. Warum gibt
es den Lackbuster nicht mal zu kaufen? Das war doch so eine tolle High-End-Netzwerk-Optimierungs-Hardware.
Ich meine, guck mal, wie geil das schon ausgesehen hat, der Lackbuster, Alter, hier. Und dann
dieses High-End-Interface. Krass, oder? Mega-Upload. Leute, muss das jetzt sein oder
muss das nicht sein? Muss. Okay. Mega-Upload.
Glaub, Mega-Upload. Wie ich einfach das Video gespiegelt habe.
Ob der wusste, in welchem Video er da landet?
Die hatten alle keinen Blassen-Schimmer, um was es überhaupt geht, ey.
Das ist cool.
Oh, mann!
Das war doch was, hä?
So ein krasser Hit!
Schon lange nicht mehr gehört hier!
Also man denkt, es kommt noch mehr, das war's im größten Teil, ne?
Mega!
Check it out!
Irgendwie kriegt man da gute Laune bei!
Ich weiß auch nicht warum!
Mega!
Okay, das war's jetzt!
Das geht die ganze Zeit so weiter jetzt!
Das war's jetzt im Endeffekt, mehr kommt da nicht!
43.000 Kommentare!
Ja, alles gut jetzt!
Mega Upload!
Oh, mann!
Das war noch was!
Es hat irgendjemand gefragt, ob jemand Mega NZ verwendet?
Eigentlich nicht!
Also sehr, sehr selten!
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das...
Ich dachte, das hat er doch, glaube ich, verkauft an irgendwelche Chinesen oder so!
Gibt's die Domain eigentlich noch?
Kann man die sich registrieren?
Nicht available!
Kann sich Mega Upload nicht registrieren!
Ja, das stimmt!
Serious Max habe ich ganz vergessen!
Der war in MW3 auf Platz 1!
Da gab's sogar ein YouTube-Video von ihm!
Mach mal Who is Mega Upload!
Kann man machen!
Ah, ist...
Äh, gibt's nix!
Gibt's nix!
Tja!
Okay, haben wir beantwortet!
Ah, Sergeant Blackburn in Stuttgart auf dem Land!
Schwer machst du finden!
Okay, da kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen!
Aber nach Ulm ist es nicht so weit, oder?
In Ulm gibt's auch relativ viel Technik-Kram!
Ich war mal bei einer Firma, die in Ulm ihren Sitz hatte!
War es bestimmt bei L.O.T.R.I.X.? Ja, genau! Ganz das wird's gewesen sein!
Scan Plus!
Äh, die kenne ich, ja! Die kenne ich!
Das war auch in der Ecke da hinten!
Nicht weit weg gewesen!
Wo ist eigentlich der Mastercrapper?
Der crappt!
Ähm, genau, das haben wir!
Äh, was für eine Firma benutzt du?
Das ist Firma Workstation!
Das habe ich schon beantwortet, ne?
Routerboard hatten wir auch schon!
C++ haben wir jetzt eigentlich lang genug durchgekaut!
Hast du irgendwo einen Guide, den du benutzt hast, um die Steckdosenleiste zu flashen?
Ja!
Das hier!
Übelst easy!
Das!
Tuya Convert!
Patrick, bringen die Leute nicht auf falsche Ideen, ne?
Ja!
Ich weiß!
Hast du auch schon lange nichts mehr von Leuten gehört, die sich ins Netzwerkkabel Lexwitch eingebaut haben?
Gibt's bestimmt immer noch!
Also, mich würd's wundern, wenn die Leute damit aufgehört hätten!
Weil mich würd's auch wundern, im gleichen Zuge, wenn das bei CoD nicht mehr möglich wäre!
Das geht da bestimmt immer noch genauso gut!
Ach, so sieht's aus!
Kennst du auch noch den Techni-Satz-Song?
Ne!
Was ist der Techni-Satz-Song?
Freiheit, die vom Himmel kommt!
Was?
Ich glaub, das wollen wir uns jetzt nicht geben!
Ach du!
Geh weg!
Techni-Satz-Schlager!
Der Techni-Satz-Song jetzt!
Hast du denn mal vom Playdate gehört?
Ist ne Art Gameboy mit ner Kurbel, ich find's ne coole Idee!
Sagt mir überhaupt nichts!
Klingt eigentlich eher wie irgendwie Sexspielzeug oder sowas, Playdate!
Keine Ahnung, was Playdate sein soll, ich will's jetzt auch nicht suchen!
Wer weiß, was man da alles findet!
Schon mal Auto-Battler wie Auto-Chess oder TFT, TFT ist das LOL-Ding, ne?
Äh, nein!
Irgendwie geht der Hype auch voll an mir vorbei!
Ich warte noch drauf, bis Crytek damit rauskommt!
Crytek war immer zu spät!
MOBA, Hype vorbei, Crytek, MOBA!
Battle Royale, Hype vorbei, Crytek, Battle Royale!
Als nächstes kommt Auto-Battler, Hype vorbei, Crytek, Auto-Battler!
Was macht Crytek eigentlich so?
Gibt's denn von denen Neues?
Achso, Far Cry 75 oder so?
Ne, nicht Far Cry, Crysis!
8?
Was machen die so?
Das ist übrigens das Crytek Battle Royale!
Was macht Crytek so?
Irgendwie nichts Interessantes!
Die machen wahrscheinlich Star Citizen Engine jetzt!
Und...
Es geht mir doch eh nicht rauskommen!
So Leute, es ist 20.51 Uhr, ne?
Wir haben, wisst ihr was wir gemacht haben von den Sachen, die wir machen wollten?
Nichts!
Nichts gemacht von dem, was wir machen wollten!
Oder was ich machen wollte!
Nichts gemacht!
Wir haben nicht in China eingekauft!
Richtig!
Außer eine Sache!
Wir haben auch kein ESP32 Multispeeding programmiert!
Das heißt eigentlich können wir morgen Abend genau wieder den gleichen Kram machen!
Ich muss ja nicht mal den Titel ändern!
Ist doch nice, oder?
Das ist mal calculated!
Das ist massiv Big Brain!
Quick Buffs!
Was macht eigentlich Big Shark so?
Gibt's von dem irgendwas Neues?
Big Shark returns!
Men don't dance!
Big Shark!
Da ist er!
Ach grad, das kann ich jetzt nicht angucken!
Big Shark hat was Neues seit heute!
Oder?
Es ist uralt!
Warum steht er denn da seit einem Tag?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Debated!
Das ist nur um mich zu debaten!
Okay, gibt nichts Neues von Big Shark!
Gibt's was Neues?
Haftbefehl 2019!
Schreier alles mit Haftbefehl!
1. Februar!
April!
Eigentlich juckt es mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht!
Stream mal morgen nicht tagsüber!
Ich bin morgen tagsüber überhaupt nicht da!
Money Boy!
Heißt Money Boy wieder Money Boy?
Der hieß doch zwischenzeitlich irgendwie SL-USB-Plug!
Frag mich nicht!
Irgendwie so ähnlich!
Was auch immer!
Eigentlich juckt mich der ganze Kram nicht!
Ich guck das eigentlich einzig und alleine, wenn ich mir so deutsche Hip Hop Geschichten angucke, einzig und allein zur Belustigung an!
Das ist alles!
Musikalische Qualität erwarte ich da nicht!
Und kriegt gefühlt auch keiner hin!
Wenn man sich mal die Texte da teilweise anhört oder auch die ganze Musik!
Also das wirkt auf mich nicht so, als ist das künstlerisch jetzt so anspruchsvoll, als könnten das nur wenige!
Das wirkt meistens ziemlich belanglos und ziemlich easy zu machen alles!
Ich glaube die größten Aufwand bei dieser 0815 Hip Hop Geschichte, haben doch die Typen, die im Studio den Scheiß halbwegs hörbar zusammen mixen müssen!
Also mir kann keiner erzählen, dass wenn man sich die Texte da teilweise durchliest, die die von sich geben, dass das wahnsinnig viel Brain erfordert, diese Dinger von sich zu dingsen!
Musikalische Qualität erwarte ich da nicht!
Max Schauheleene Fischer, ja, ganz bestimmt!
Das einzige, was mir das anreizt, ist fürs Reihen und alleine zur Belustigung!
Ich finde es immer geil, wie viele das dann ernst nehmen!
Obbei ich glaube ja, Money Boy ist mittlerweile auch so ursprünglich mal so alles Verarschung gestartet und mittlerweile ist er da wahrscheinlich voll drauf hängen geblieben!
Musikalische Qualität erwarte ich da nicht!
Was darf es denn aus China sein? Ja eigentlich ganz viel, aber wir sind nicht wirklich dazu gekommen!
Was für Musik ist was für dich?
Hauptsächlich Hard Rock, Heavy Metal, das Beste!
Obbei, wie gesagt, ich gebe mir auch mal die ein oder anderen Hip-Hop Geschichten, obbei die Deutschen nur zur Belustigung, das kann ich nicht ernst nehmen!
Also das meiste habe da kann ich nicht ernst nehmen und von den meisten Musikalischen Qualitäten bin ich da auch nicht überzeugt!
Ich meine bei Helene Fischer hast du wenigstens tatsächlich was zu schauen!
Anhören würde ich sie mir nicht unbedingt!
Findet ihr auch so wenig Azubi Interessenten für die Informatikberufe? Es ist schwierig die letzten Jahre, es sind doch bei uns relativ wenige!
Genau, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, Zahl die Kollektion, Bar, Fick auf Sponsor!
Das sind die einzigen paar Zeilen, haftbefehl, die ich auswendig kann!
Informatik ist überall beliebt, ja aber wir finden wenig, vielleicht wollen auch einfach wenige zu uns, kann auch sein, aber es sind in den letzten Jahren, zu den letzten 2-3 Jahren sind es erstaunlich wenig Systemintegration Azubis gewesen!
Max hast du schon gehört, dass Bird das Wort ist? Ich bin 35, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr was du sagen willst vor 96!
Hast du eben einen Ultraschallensensor bestellt? Nee? Wie kommst du drauf?
Das ist allerdings eine Sache, die tatsächlich auf meiner To-Do-Liste steht, für China-Einkäufe, die wir heute eigentlich machen wollten, nehme ich den Ultraschallensensor, der nur 3,3 Volt braucht!
Weil mein, den ich habe, braucht er leider 5 Volt! Und ich habe geguckt, der Nachfolger, der braucht eine 3,3 und ich habe das bei einem Shop in England bestellt, allerdings hat das jetzt eine Woche gedauert und kam nicht an!
Ich vermute mal, die haben mich skirmast oder es ist irgendwo untergegangen oder so!
Das ist aus Family Guy, ok, muss die nicht!
Warum fragst du Eichelris? Bester Name!
Du hast gerade was tolles gefunden, Aliexpress! Ok, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, was er gefunden hat!
Da sieht man halt, wie der China beste, guck mal wie günstig der China Kram ist!
Hier bezahlst du vorneweg 3-4 Euro für den gleichen Sensor! Wichtig ist, dass du den hier kriegst!
Der ist 5 Volt, der ist 5 Volt, äh, das ist der gleiche, der ist 5 Volt und der ist 3,3 Volt!
Und nachdem man hier jetzt nicht auswählen kann, was man für den Sensor haben will, ist es doof!
Oder kann man hier irgendwo auswählen, welchen der beiden Sensoren man haben will?
Warum darf ich eigentlich Aliexpress aufmachen, ohne dass ich mich einloggen muss?
Ah, jetzt muss ich mich wieder einloggen! Das ist Random Lootboxen!
Ich bräuchte Chromium, womit ich das mit meinem alten Chrome syncen kann! Keine Ahnung, ob ich den gemacht habe!
Chromium Installer, einfach mal gucken, Chromium Windows Builds!
Hier, da, die habe ich auch! Kannst du den Installer nehmen oder das Portable?
Wie du das da mit Chrome syncen kriegst, weiß ich nicht!
Ähm, wie sonst? Ich glaube, das liegt daran, wenn man aus dem Unity-Media-Netz kommt! Weil, beispielsweise auf der Arbeit muss ich das nicht!
Und ich glaube, vom Telekom Anschluss müsste ich das auch nicht!
Also, wenn die hier jetzt eine Auswahl hätten, ne? Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an! Das ist schon massiv billig, ne?
So, dann nimmt man... Versand aus China nimmt man am besten...
Die haben hier kein EU-Priority-Line!
Das kostet die Finnland! Da bleibt ja eigentlich fast nur EMS-Paket übrig!
Ich meine, das ist schon übertrieben billig, ne?
Ich meine, du kannst hier 20 Sensoren holen für irgendwie 10 Euro!
Also 15 Euro aus, hast 20 Sensoren inklusive Versand! Das ist schon billig, ja!
Kann man sich Sachen aus China bestellen, ohne dass einem die Steckdosen explodieren? Man muss ein bisschen drauf gucken...
Man muss ein bisschen drauf gucken, was man kauft!
Also, generell bei den meisten Sachen, wo 230 Volt drüber gehen, bin ich kein großartiger Fan von China-Ware!
Erstmal von dieser Steckdosen-Leiste, die wir letztens geflasht haben, abgesehen!
Deswegen habe ich auch keine Sonos oder sowas!
Aber bei allem anderen kann man China-Zeug holen!
Achso, ja! Wo ich auch nicht China-Zeugs holen würde, sind Akkus und Batterien!
Das ist Crap von China-Seiten!
Da kriegst du irgendwie so einen billigen Scheiß, der dir dann um die Ohren fliegt oder abfackelt oder sowas!
Das würde ich nicht machen!
Alles, was mit Lebensmitteln in Büro kommt, ja gut, das würde ich auch nicht machen!
Gibt es einen E-Mode für Monka-Smoke?
Das sind meine Twitch! Ha, lustig!
Wenn du nach Monka-Smoke suchst, findest du Clips von Mildstreams!
Monka-Smoke!
Ja, das ist ja fast schon etwas wie Monka-Smoke!
Aber ich hätte gerne einen E-Mode, was wirklich Monka-Smoke heißt!
Irgendwie heißt das so ein abfackeltes China-Ding! Den wollte ich mal überlegen, vielleicht machen wir einen E-Mode!
Genau, übrigens, diese Sensoren standen bei mir auch jetzt auf der Kaufliste, die ich mir eigentlich holen wollte heute im Stream bei China-Anbietern!
Also wie gesagt, habe ich noch keinen bestellt! China kann ich mir nicht, das stimmt!
Jupp!
Falls man nicht übernommen wird nach der Ausbildung, wenn du nicht übernommen wirst nach der Ausbildung, kannst du genau das machen in der Zeit, was dich interessiert!
Weil, umso besser du dich auskennst in dem Bereich, der dich interessiert, umso einfacher kriegst du auch einen Job in dem Bereich, der dich interessiert!
Und dann profitieren ja alle von!
Lerne einfach das in dem Bereich, was dich interessiert!
Generell, ich würde nur Sachen lernen, so privat und wenn es von mir ausgeht, Sachen, die mich interessieren, weil ansonsten fehlt mir der Antrieb!
Ich könnte beispielsweise nie im Leben sagen, hey, ich weiß, Cobol-Programmierer werden gut bezahlt, ich lerne Cobol!
Das würde ich dann machen!
Wofür braucht man denn ein Ultraschall-Sensor?
Ja, gucken, ob du schwanger bist!
Was sonst?
Apropos, was hatten wir gerade?
Nein!
Ein Ultraschall-Sensor kannst du zum Beispiel verwenden, um zu gucken, wie voll ein Wassertank ist, oder als Abstandsmesser, wie weit du von einem Objekt entfernt bist!
Oder aber, wofür ich ihn verwenden will, im Briefkasten bzw. im Zeitungsrohr, ob was drin steckt!
Dafür kann man zum Beispiel Ultraschall-Sensor verwenden!
Ob was im Rohr steckt, ey Leute, jetzt geht es wieder los hier!
Kannst du den Sensor nicht irgendwie extra poweren?
Hä?
Ich habe eine Batterie, für 3,3V?
Ich könnte so einen Step-Up-Dings dazwischen stecken!
Ja, das würde funktionieren!
Das Problem mit dem 5V-Sensor ist, ich habe nicht so einfach einen Pin mit 5V.
Da müsste ich so einen Step-Up-Converter dazwischen machen, dann aus 3,3V 5V macht.
Das Problem ist dann wiederum, die Datenleitungen für die GPIO-Pins sind dann auch 5V und das Board braucht 3,3V.
Das heißt, ich müsste für diesen Sensor erstmal 3,3V zu 5V konvertieren und dann die Datenleitungen wieder von 5V auf 3,3V.
Das ist das Board nicht kaputt, das lohnt sich nicht.
Und außerdem braucht das auch noch Strom.
Wozu soll ich das machen? Ich kaufe mir einfach für 50 Cent einen 3,3V-Sensor.
Ja, aber selbst das, das braucht alles ohne Strom im Batteriebetrieb.
Das Beste ist ein 3,3V-Sensor.
Wo bloß und schätzt, kann jemand einen dünnen DNS-Anbieter empfehlen oder gibt es andere Möglichkeiten?
Ja, ich kann einen dünnen DNS-Anbieter empfehlen.
Den verwende ich selbst.
DuckDNS. Beste.
Kostenlos.
Unterstützt die wichtigsten Sachen zum Anmelden.
GitHub, Reddit, Twitter, Google.
Total einfach.
Und lässt sich super easy mit Curl aktualisieren.
Unterstützt auch TXT-Records.
Das heißt, du kannst sogar Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate beantragen.
Beste.
Ja, das ist mal ein High-End-Logo, oder? Für einen Dienst.
Absolutes High-End-Logo.
Das ist übrigens auch mal so ein Dienst, wo man sich überlegen kann, wenn man den verwendet.
Weil der ist komplett kostenlos.
So ein Dienst, wo man sich überlegen kann, ob man den Typ nicht mal supportet mit 1-2 Euro im Monat.
Oder kleine Donation oder sowas.
Ich meine, allein schon seine Sauberkosten. Und dass er ein bisschen was über hat, wäre nicht verkehrt.
Ja, den kann ich aber empfehlen.
Wie sieht's mit Partnerbewerbung aus? Noch nicht raus.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich mach das auch. Diesmal mach ich das.
Diesmal mach ich wirklich Partner-Antrag.
Wofür braucht man nun? Haben wir schon mal Antworten? Langsam erwarten wir die? Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Spannungsteil hatten wir auch gerade.
Nextcloud nichts mehr im Weg.
Wobei ich da aufpassen würde.
Also ich würde meine Nextcloud-Instanz auf gar keinen Fall öffentlich ins Internet hängen.
Sollte das mal wirklich irgendwelche Security-Probleme haben?
Also das PHP oder Nextcloud an sich, da können die Leute direkt auf dein Zeug zugreifen aus dem Internet.
Von wöchentlich streamen habe ich nichts gesagt. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass ich mich partnermäßig bewerben werde.
Man muss nicht unbedingt wöchentlich streamen, wenn man Partner ist. Allerdings ist es natürlich blöd zu sagen.
Auch rein aus Usersicht.
Also Twitch erwartet schon eine gewisse regelmäßige Sache.
Allerdings musst du ja auch, bevor du dich als Partner bewirbst, erstmal eine gewisse Zeit gestreamt haben.
Und in der Regel bist du einmal Partner, immer Partner, sei denn du baust übertrieben Scheiße.
Zumindest hat mir das mal jemand so erklärt.
Aber es ist natürlich auch für die Zuschauer kacke, wenn es dann welche gibt, die dich supporten.
Das ist ja auch gefühlt zumindest eine gewisse Verpflichtung.
Kannst du nicht erst in ein halbes Jahr dich verdrücken.
Wie gesagt, ich würde mein Nextcloud auf keinen Fall direkt ins Internet hängen.
Das Beste ist, wenn du von außen drauf zugreifen willst und Kontrolle über deine Endgeräte hast, machen VPN.
Das ist das Einfachste.
Ist egal welches, aber machen VPN. Das ist easy, das ist sicher.
Da würde ich mir keine Gedanken zu machen.
VPN daheim einwählen und auf den Nextcloud zugreifen.
Das ist so sicher, da würde ich mir keine Gedanken zu machen.
Würde ich auch bedenkenlos empfehlen, würde ich auch bedenkenlos selbst so machen.
Wenn du nicht unbedingt Kontrolle über die Endgeräte hast, wenn du dich z.B. von deinem Arbeitsnotebook einloggen willst,
was halt nicht dein Endgerät ist, dann würde ich mir überlegen, als erstes muss das unbedingt sein.
Und wenn ja, würde ich zumindest einen Reverseproxy davor stellen, der Authentifizierungsgedöns macht
und dahinter dann die Nextcloud, die im Zweifelsfall nochmal Authentifizierung wacht, wenn es sein muss.
Aber direkt ins Internet hängen würde ich es nicht.
Ich würde da zumindest einen EngineX Reverseproxy oder sowas davor stellen.
Reicht dir der Fritz-Dienst von VPN? Ja klar, besser als nichts.
Wenn die Endgeräte alle dein sind, mach VPN.
Und wenn du nicht das von der Fritzbox verwenden willst, kannst du dir auch ohne Probleme deinen Raspberry dahinter stellen an die Fritzbox
und leitest den Port weiter über die Fritzbox an den Raspberry für VPN und machst VPN auf den Raspberry.
Ja, gut. PPTP...
Ja, okay, du kannst nicht alles verwenden. Ich meinte alles heute gängige.
Kannst du auch in China VPN Lösungen verwenden?
Also im Prinzip gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, die verbreitet sind.
Das ist OpenVPN und IPsec. Und jetzt neuerdings auch recht angesagt WireGuard.
Niki ist noch auf dem Rad. Erhofft, ich bleibe länger an.
Niki, ich glaube, das wird nichts mehr.
22 Uhr spätestens ist Schluss, weil ich ins Bett muss. Morgen wieder 5.45 Uhr aufstehen.
Aber das Schöne ist, ihr wisst ja, vier Tage Arbeitswoche nur.
Immer vier Tage nur. Das ist zwar eine der besten Entscheidungen ever.
Das würde ich jederzeit wieder so machen.
Schenkst du dem Grill dieses Jahr wieder was zu Weihnachten?
Vielleicht. Mal gucken. Ich hatte mit dem Grill jetzt schon eine Weile nichts mehr zu tun.
Ich glaube, das Grill war ein bisschen davon abgeschreckt, dass ich so...
Wie nennt man das so?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man sagen kann, so wenig interessiert, so antisozial bin.
Dass mich zwischenmenschliche Sachen nicht so im Fokus stehen bei mir.
Habe ich mir jetzt schon öfters darüber ausgelassen, muss ich jetzt heute nicht nochmal machen.
Habe ich auch schon gesagt.
Ja genau, VPN. Oder zumindest mal eine Reverse-Proxy dazwischen.
Wo man sich dann überlegen kann, was man für eine Authentifizierungsmaßnahme nimmt.
Reverse-Proxy mit Basic-OS dazwischen ist immer noch besser, wie das Ding direkt ins Interesse stellen.
Reverse-Proxy mit Basic-OS ist eigentlich super easy eingerichtet. Und im Zweifelsfall macht man nochmal Authentifizierung gegen die Nextcloud dahinter.
Ich dachte jetzt, wo du so viel streamst, wirst du regelmäßig streamen.
Ich bin ja noch ein bisschen hin und her gerissen. Das muss ich jetzt vielleicht an der Stelle mal erzählen mit dem Stream.
Ich finde das sehr nice, die ganzen Technik-Streams, die man machen.
Und ich finde es auch unglaublich nice, dass so viele Leute immer zugucken.
Das ist ja nun wirklich kein Thema, was jetzt die breite Masse anspricht.
Also wenn ich hier irgendwelche ESP32-Sachen programmiere oder chinaische Technik-Kram kaufe oder irgendwie C-Sharp was programmiere, das ist ja nichts.
So führt den Mainstream im Endeffekt.
Ursprünglich angefangen mit diesen Technik-Streams habe ich ja, weil es keine Games gibt, die mich interessieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll, so richtig mal angenommen. Es kommt jetzt Bad Company 3 raus und ich finde es übelst nice.
Dann werde ich wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein bisschen Bad Company 3 spielen.
Was man sich halt auch überlegen muss ist, Streams kosten natürlich viel Zeit.
Das heißt, das ist eine Sache, die mache ich nur, wenn die Zeit sich für mich nicht irgendwie anfühlt, als wäre sie verschwendet, was sie ja nicht macht.
Und ich denke auch mal, das Publikum, was man erreichen kann mit Technik-Streams, ist begrenzt in Deutschland.
Ziemlich begrenzt.
Also manchmal habe ich so in der Spitze 200 Zuschauer bei so Technik-Zeug.
Ich denke allzu viel mehr wird es nicht.
Weil ich glaube, es gibt einfach, vor allem auf Twitch gucken auch nicht so viele.
Wo ich immer relativ viele Zuschauer habe, da hatten wir glaube ich mal sogar 500 oder irgendwie sowas, war immer in der Spitze.
War, als wir E3-Streams gemacht haben und E3-Streams und was andere war Gamescom, Pressekonferenz und sowas.
Da haben immer richtig viele geguckt.
Da habe ich schon so ein bisschen gemonker, shaked so viele Leute, die dazu geguckt haben.
Aber so diese reinen Technik-Sachen interessieren sich auch nicht so extrem viele.
Face Revealed, 20.000 Zuschauer, Quatsch.
Das interessiert eigentlich kein Mensch, wie ich ausschaue.
Außerdem gibt es sogar Videos, wo man mich sieht.
WireGuard habe ich mir schon aufgeschrieben, wollen wir in einem der nächsten Streams machen.
Habe ich mir schon aufgeschrieben.
Warten wir schon, warten wir auch schon.
Welchen Raspberry empfiehlst du?
Den Künstlichsten, der ausreicht für das, was du machen willst.
Was willst du machen?
Nicky ist jetzt da.
Von wann bis wann arbeitest du?
Ein bisschen unterschiedlich, je nachdem welcher Tag das ist.
Also montags arbeite ich gar nicht.
Dienstags, Mittwochs, Donnerstags arbeite ich meistens von so 7.10 Uhr bis 15.30 Uhr.
Und Freitags meistens so von 7.15 bis 13.30 bis 14.30 Uhr.
Was ist dein Job?
Generell so als kleiner Server Ersatz, Steuerung von Sachen.
Also wenn du wirklich einen kleinen kleinen kleinen Server Ersatz suchst und wenn du wirklich nur Sachen steuern willst, dann würde ich mir einen Raspberry Zero W nehmen.
Das ist der kleinste, der schwächste, allerdings der kompakteste und auch den, den man am einfachsten betreiben kann.
Der passt in jede Ecke, einen Zero W.
Der ist aber nicht schnell im Vergleich zu den anderen.
Der hat nur einen Kern und ich glaube auch nur einen 800 Mhz Kern.
Also der Zero ist wirklich nicht der schnellste.
Für VPN, es geht nicht um VPN.
Er hat geschrieben, es geht um kleiner Server Ersatz, Steuerung von Sachen.
Für VPN würde ich keinen Zero nehmen.
Mein Gehalt ist dafür zu privat.
Ich weiß selbst gar nicht, wie viel ich genau gerade kriege.
Ich rechne das immer nur nach, wenn es irgendwie gerade darum geht.
Es reicht auf jeden Fall.
Mit YouTube verdiene ich ja aktuell nicht wirklich was.
YouTube habe ich letzten, habe ich diesen Monat glaube ich 35 Euro oder so gekriegt oder 35 Dollar.
Was hast du für einen Abschluss? Ich habe mal irgendwann 2000, frag mich nicht.
Eins, ich weiß nicht, ewig her, habe ich mittlere Reife gemacht.
Danach habe ich mich ziemlich viel in allen möglichen Sachen rumgetrieben.
Ich habe sogar mal angefangen Bürokaufmann zu lernen, so BWL Shit.
Wo ich dann irgendwann gemerkt habe, Alter ist das ein Kack, da habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ich habe relativ lange gebraucht, bis ich dann da gelandet bin, was ich jetzt mache.
Es ist nicht so viel, dass ich die Zahlen nicht im Kopf habe, aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Das ändert sich ja auch immer mal, je nach ob es irgendwie tarifvertragmäßig was gibt oder eine Bonusgeschichte.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Außerdem ist es nichts, was ich großartig breit treten will, wahrscheinlich im Stream.
Ich muss mir mal überlegen, was ich da zu erzählen will.
Vier Tage, wo musst du dich bewerben?
Das ist kein Problem, das kannst du eigentlich bei den meisten Arbeitgebern heutzutage machen.
Und umso jünger die Leute sind, umso mehr ist das für die wichtig.
Es gibt auch Rumfragen zu und viele Leute sagen heutzutage, hey, arbeiten ist nicht mehr alles.
Und ich finde das gerade cool, dass das immer mehr jüngere Leute sagen.
Weil, wenn man sich das mal ehrlich anguckt, ich glaube, es gibt niemanden,
mal angenommen, heute ist so euer letzter Tag und ihr wisst, in fünf Minuten kratzt ihr ab.
Ich glaube kaum einer wird sagen, ja, hätte ich in meinem Leben noch mal mehr gearbeitet.
Ich glaube die meisten Leute werden sagen, ey, hätte ich mal mehr Zeit gehabt für, keine Ahnung, Kinder, Frau, Familie.
Einfach machen, wo ich Bock drauf habe.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich, was sich die meisten Leute denken werden.
Deswegen finde ich es gut, dass gerade jüngere Leute mittlerweile sagen, es ist ihnen besonders wichtig,
dass das alles irgendwie schön im Einklang ist.
Deswegen, vier Tage Woche ist eigentlich kein Problem.
Die meisten Arbeitgeber haben damit keine Probleme.
Und also heutzutage wenig Probleme, zumindest im Technikumfeld.
Und außerdem darf da so ohne weiteres ein Arbeitgeber auch gar nichts tun.
Darf da so ohne weiteres ein Arbeitgeber auch gar nichts dabei dagegen sagen.
Also der kann dich nicht einfach rausschmeißen, weil du sagst, der Chef, ich will gerne Teilzeit arbeiten.
Natürlich sollte man gucken, dass man mit seinem Chef da irgendwie eine ordentliche Lösung findet, ja.
Wie bist du zum Programmieren gekommen?
Boah, das war das erste, was ich damals programmiert habe.
Und warum?
Das habe ich bestimmt schon mal erzählt, aber ich kann mich gerade nicht dran erinnern.
Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht weiß es einer, weil ich schon mal im Stream erzählt habe.
Also angefangen habe ich damals mit, ich habe mir mal ein Python Buch gekauft, schon ewig her.
Das war noch uralt Python Version.
Davor habe ich auch ein bisschen mal mit C rumgespielt.
Aber so richtig angefangen habe ich eigentlich damals, als ich ein bisschen unter Windows rumgebastelt habe
und mir, das war damals Urschel Studio 2003 oder 2005 war das, glaube ich.
Da gab es noch C Sharp Express und sowas.
Und da habe ich mir ein C Sharp Buch geholt und habe angefangen.
Das war das so, wo ich wirklich angefangen habe richtig programmieren zu lernen.
Und ich muss sagen, und das haben wahrscheinlich viele und wahrscheinlich haben sie gleichermaßen wenige,
dass die ihre erste Sprache, mit der sie angefangen haben zu programmieren,
für immer für die tollste Sprache halten.
Oder gerade Leute, die mit sowas angefangen haben mit C++, die das für immer hassen.
Kannst du einen Python Buch empfehlen? Nee, nee, habe ich zu lange nichts gelesen zu.
Na Flo, wenn du schon breit genug bist, dann ist alles gut.
Welche Reverse-Proxy empfiehlst du einfach aufzusetzen? Also ich nehme immer Nginx.
Nginx ist nicht der einfachste zu konfigurieren, dafür kann er viel.
Was ziemlich beliebt ist in letzter Zeit, was ich immer wieder lese, was ich aber selbst noch nie verwendet habe,
ist, wie heißt der Kram, Caddy und Traffic und ein paar verwenden auch HA-Proxy.
Aber ich glaube Caddy und Traffic sind so die angesachten Halbdinger zurzeit.
Ich persönlich schwöre auf Nginx und ich verwende eigentlich für alles,
wo man einen Reverse-Proxy oder einen Web-Server braucht, Nginx.
Nginx schreibt man übrigens so, frag mich nicht warum, also weil Nginx, aber ich verschreibe mich jedes Mal.
Metro Last Light habe ich immer noch nicht gekauft.
Stream einfach, wo du Bock hast. Ja, so sieht es aus. Fettviel hatten wir schon.
Wo ich richtig hyped wäre, ist ein Format, bei dem du dir von irgendwelchen Technik-Convention-Streams machst.
Es gibt fast jede Woche so ein Event. Du meinst, dass wir uns zusammen die Livestreams angucken oder was?
Ja, wenn euch das interessiert. Ich gucke eh relativ viel in der Richtung. Schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Das könnten wir echt mal machen, wenn irgendwas ist. Zum Beispiel, Apple Developer-Konferenz-Geschiss war gerade erst.
Aber dazu hätten wir super einen Stream machen können.
Und da können wir uns wieder anhören. Die Most Awesome Experience of Awesomeness.
Oder, Moment, Clip Wupplors. Hier, das war gestern, war es so.
Wupplors Luftschachtstelze?
Achtung, kommt der krasse Luftschachtstelze.
Das ist doch ein Luftschachtstelze.
Was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte. Gestern haben wir uns ein bisschen was von der Bild angeguckt.
Das war halt übelst cringe Fremdschirm.
Das tut echt richtig weh.
Alter, du hast mal was gezockt auf Twitch.
Ja, sogar heute Morgen. Wir haben sogar heute Morgen was gespielt. So. Also ab und zu spiele ich mal was.
Das machen wir. Das finde ich gut.
Falls du da, falls du irgendwelche aktuellen Vorschläge hast, was es so gibt, sag ruhig Bescheid.
Weil, es kann durchaus sein, ich gucke zwar relativ viel, aber meistens gucke ich Zusammenfassungen danach,
weil ich gar nicht mitkriege, dass gerade irgendwas live ist.
Also hier an den Patreons, wenn dir irgendwas auffällt, kannst du mir das ruhig im Discord schreiben,
oder hier im Stream schreiben, oder auf Twitter schreiben, oder generell könnt ihr mir das immer auf Twitter schreiben,
wenn irgendwo eine Veranstaltung mit Livestream ist, was wir zusammen im Stream angucken wollen.
Ich meine, die großen Sachen irgendwie wie E3, Gamescom ist jetzt demnächst auch wieder.
Mal gucken, ob es da irgendwas gibt, oder irgendwie Build von Microsoft,
diese Apple Developer-Konferenz, klar, kriege ich auch mit.
Aber es gibt bestimmt auch jede Menge anderes Zeug, was ich verpasse.
Was ist mein Job-Beruf? Hatten wir schon. Abschluss hatten wir auch schon.
Wie hast du die vier Tage Woche ausgehandelt mit deinem Geld? Verdienst du jetzt einfach einen Tag mit... Joa.
Exakt. Genau so. Wobei es halt in der Summe, sowas unten rauskommt, gar nicht so viel weniger ist.
Kein Uni-Abschuss, nein.
Ich kriege Dinge per Paste bin geschickt.
Achso, das hatten wir doch vorhin schon mal.
Oder hast du... Ah nee, du hast es jetzt erweitert. Büro, Schreibtisch.
Äh, also... Hat sich beim Discord was geändert? Nee, es gibt noch kein Discord.
Ähm, naja, das mit dem Verdienen habe ich jetzt ja schon was zu gesagt, dass ich mir erstmal Gedanken...
Wie kann man am schnellsten Programm... Ich finde Coden ist ein ganz schlimmes Wort.
Ich sage immer Programmieren.
Weil beim Programmieren geht es nicht nur um das Schreiben von Source Code.
Da geht es eigentlich zu 90% ums Nachdenken und danach den Kram irgendwie auf Papier, also in den Editor bringen.
Niki, wir gucken uns das dann... Also falls du den nächsten Stream noch was hast, was wir uns angucken sollen, können wir uns das dann angucken.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich muss um 22 Uhr pennen.
Broggen, Broggen ist natürlich auch was.
Drei Tage, ja, nein. Das ist... Die Skolte hat voll und ganz recht.
Freizeit generell. Sachen, die man macht, weil man sie selbst machen will, ist im Prinzip das Beste.
Und letztendlich, wenn man sich überlegt, um was geht es im Leben, bestimmt nicht den ganzen Tag zu arbeiten, sondern eigentlich das zu machen, worauf man Bock hat.
So viel wie möglich, so viel, was einem irgendwie quasi erlaubt ist, das zu machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Also wenn es danach geht, sollte man vielleicht das Heiraten und Kinderkriegen vermeiden.
Dann kann man relativ wenig machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Aber das muss jeder selbst wissen.
Ich hab euch schon mal gesagt, ich mag keine Menschen und ich mag noch weniger Kinder.
Also für mich stellt sich die Frage aktuell so ähnlich.
Tja, wie kann man am schnellsten programmieren in Python lernen?
Tja.
Wie kann man am schnellsten programmieren lernen?
Ich würde sagen, eine Mischung aus sich ein ordentliches Buch kaufen.
Das ist für mich immer noch das Beste, wie man neue Technik lernt.
Webcasts gucken.
Vielleicht den ein oder anderen Online-Kurs machen, der was taugt.
Und dabei auf jeden Fall sich überlegen, ob es ein Projekt gibt, was man wirklich umsetzen möchte.
Weil ich meine, es hat ja vielleicht den Sinn, dass du sagst, ich möchte jetzt unbedingt Python,
denn weil ich möchte, keine Ahnung, irgendwas machen.
Ich möchte TensorFlow irgendwelche Bilderkennung machen oder so.
Irgendwas ist ja gerade angesagt, oder?
Vielleicht hast du irgendwas im Kopf, wo du sagst, das will ich unbedingt machen.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie.
Das ist eigentlich so die beste Motivation, das zu lernen,
wenn man nämlich dem immer näher kommt, was man eigentlich machen will.
Und dann halt, wie gesagt, eine Mischung, ein ordentliches Buch, Webcasts.
Und halt nicht rein beschallen lassen, sondern halt ausprobieren.
Weil beim Ausprobieren fallen einem halt viele Sachen auf, warum sie so sind, wie sie sind.
Minecraft Plugins, genau.
Das ist ein super Beispiel.
Genau so was meine ich.
Ähm, hier, der Zagor.
Warte, hast du eigentlich ein Net hinten dran, wegen irgendwie.NET, oder?
Also Zagornets war der Meinung, okay, ihr braucht eine Minecraft Plugin.
Wie mache ich das am besten?
Und das ist die beste Motivation, programmieren zu lernen.
Wenn du sagst, ah, ich spiele Minecraft, ich hätte gerne die und die Funktion.
Da gibt es nichts für und ich würde gerne Minecraft Plugin programmieren.
Dann ist es relativ einfach.
Du sagst, okay, Minecraft Server, was brauche ich da für eine Sprache?
In was macht man das?
Aha, Java, also muss ich Java lernen.
Easy, Entscheidung gefallen.
Weil ich gar nicht weiß, ob die neuen Sachen noch in Java sind.
Ja, das haben wir beantwortet.
In 60 Jahren stirbt er alleine, so wie ich mich kenne kann das schon sein.
Allerdings, ich bin nicht alleine.
In 60 Jahren mache ich Livestream, wenn ich dann, ich kratze dann irgendwann im Livestream ab.
Oder auf YouTube oder so.
Während gerade gebashed wird.
Da wird gerade Cod 2075 gebashed.
Und dann rege ich mich auf, dass ich across the map getommerhawked wurde und dann gebe ich den Löffel ab.
Dann spammt der ganze Chat F, ey, das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Was passiert mit deinem YouTube-Channel, wenn ich...
Alter, Leute, ich bin zwar nächsten Monat 35, aber ich werde nicht demnächst ins Gras beißen.
Ich habe es sogar abgenommen wieder.
Jetzt schon sieben Wochen in Folge.
Kannst du den Preisenbuch gar nicht empfehlen?
Warten wir schon.
Hast du den Code für den Chatcode?
Zorgst du denn zur Zeit überhaupt noch irgendwas?
Last Light Summer Sale
Ja, vielleicht wird es doch mal Zeit.
Nieders Bullshit Bingo, ja, Bullshit Bingo.
Discord haben wir schon, Broggenpa...
Haha, da ist keiner, das ist der Plan schlechthin.
Einfach keine Ahnung, ob die nicht schon 18 sind.
Genau das.
Kennst du Sprache SCL und ST?
Structured Control Language Bestellung strukturierter...
Was?
Strukturierter Text klingt für mich ein bisschen wie Magda und so.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
SCL.
Das ist Clock.
Strukturierter Text.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie EMAX Org Mode.
Ist das sowas wie Pascal?
Oder ist das sowas wie ein Struktogramm in...
Nee, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Ja, kriegst du dann.
Wenn du den dann noch brauchen kannst zu dem...
In dem ja, dann ist der Sauber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr OP.
Hat deine Waage auch ein Webinterface?
Nee.
Die Waage, die ich habe, ist sowas von Oldschool.
Die hat noch nicht mal eine digitale Anzeige.
Die hat ein Gewicht, was man hin und her schiebt.
Das ist nicht von mir Oldschool, das ist Retro.
Kiltastream als Testament.
Da müssen sich dann andere mit beschäftigen.
Ah, Pascal.
Ich dachte mir schon, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Pascal.
Also hier, Whitelight, ich habe keine Ahnung, was du mir damit sagen wolltest.
Mit hast du den Code für den Chatcode.
Nope.
Also, wenn das in diesem Tempo weitergeht, schon.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird auch weniger.
Könntest du nicht mal dein Memetool umbauen,
dass der Twitchstream das Memetool übernehmen kann?
Ich will ja schon die ganze Zeit das Memetool nochmal neu ordentlich basteln.
Das wäre natürlich ein schönes...
Denn ich plug in eine schöne Funktion, dass man sagen könnte, Twitch Chat kann Emotes einblenden.
HTML und CSS, beste Programmiersprache.
Generell, HTML, CSS.
Beste.
Allerbeste.
STS, Pascal.
Musst du dein Hightech-Klo patchen?
Leider hat mein Klo keine ordentliche Schnittstelle, um sich da irgendwie dran zu attachen.
Habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, ob es nicht vielleicht eine Möglichkeit gäbe,
dass ich da einen ESP8266 oder sowas neben unter die Abdeckung vom Klo mache
und vielleicht auslesen kann, wie der Füllstand ist von der Spülflüssigkeit
oder wie die Temperatur ist oder wie der Filterstand ist.
Leider habe ich dazu keine Möglichkeit gefunden bisher.
Hat dein Klo Laura?
Leider ist das...
Das ist zwar schon ein recht smartes Klo mit vielen Komfortfunktionen,
allerdings ist es leider nicht so modern, dass man es flashen kann oder irgendwie mit einer API auslesen kann.
Das wäre natürlich extrem nice.
Das hatte ich mir übrigens schon aufgeschrieben.
Mit dem Meme-Tool.
Achso, hast du den Code für den Chat?
Ach, du meinst den Source-Code vom Pepega-Board?
Das könnte ich eigentlich pushen, ja.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger recht fertig eigentlich und auch recht übersichtlich.
Okay.
Das ist die Sharp.
Unten drunter und ein bisschen JavaScript.
Und natürlich sind Twitch-Emails das programmiert.
Industrierer habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich auch keinen Sonoff verwende.
Ich traue den Dingern nicht richtig, zumal man dort die Kabel für aufschneiden muss und reinmachen.
Irgendwie mag ich das ganze Sonoff-Konzept nicht.
Dann hole ich mir lieber eine Steckdosenleiste, die ich flashen kann.
Haben wir ja gemacht letztens.
Also das Ding hat so etwas, was aussieht wie eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Aber ich habe dazu nichts gefunden.
Ich glaube 8000 plus ist es.
Ja.
Ich habe dazu...
Nee, da zeigt nicht die Technik.
Genau, hier neben hat es so was, das kann man an der Seite aufmachen, da ist die Technik drin.
Was noch am ehesten funktioniert, ist glaube ich die Fernbedienung anzapfen.
Hä, das ist kein Witz mit dem Klo.
Also so wirklich smart ist das Klo nicht.
Das hat nur schön viele Funktionen.
Das kann man heizen lassen, das hat einen Föhn, das hat, also, Trockenpusten.
Das hat Luftabsaugung, verschiedene Profile, den Winkel, wie das das Wasser sprühen soll, mehr Wasser, weniger Wasser, Zeug.
Ich absenk Automatik.
Also ich glaube am weitesten kommt man noch damit, wenn man die Fernbedienung irgendwie anzapft.
Warum braucht man sowas, weil es sehr angenehm ist.
Das braucht man erst, wenn man es mal hatte, dann merkt man, oder besser gesagt, wenn man es mal hatte und nicht mehr hat, merkt man, dass einem was fehlt.
Seitdem ich das Klo habe, gehe ich eigentlich nirgendswo anders mehr aufs Klo.
Wenn es sich nicht vermeiden lässt.
Man findet leider hier kein Bild mit der Technik.
Das hat so ein bisschen was nebendran, was aussieht wie eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Hier sieht man schon ein bisschen was.
Ich such mal nach GitHub.
Ja, Brandgefahr habe ich euch ja erzählt, wo sie davor gewarnt haben, dass das Klo brennen kann.
Klo hat schlechte Bewertung.
Guck mal, der hat nen C-Sharp-Programm, wo man sich zu seinem Klo verbinden kann.
Ist doch ganz interessant.
Vielleicht funktioniert das auch bei meinem Klo.
Das muss ich mir mal speichern.
Mit dem Raspberry, okay.
Und wie verbindet das sich?
Bluetooth? Ah fuck, nee, mein Klo hat keinen Bluetooth.
Das ist zu alt.
Is ain't shower running?
Hektale.
Nope, hier ist nichts mit Injection.
Auto-Refresh, das Board Auto-Refreshed.
Was meinste denn, warum da hinten dran Refresh gleich Null steht?
Da steht dran, dass es nicht Refreshed.
Ansonsten Refresh das jede Sekunde.
Aber von meinem ganzen Smart-Home-Gedöns, kennst du HyperJS? Ja.
Von meinem ganzen Smart-Home-Gedöns ist eigentlich die Steuerung vom Klo für mich aktuell das Uninteressanteste,
weil das Klo musst du prinzipiell nur steuern, wenn du eh drauf bist und dann hast du die Fernbedienung oder die Knöpfe an der Seite.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich da machen will mit.
Und wenn, dann würde ich versuchen irgendwie mir eine Fernbedienung zu besorgen und versuchen irgendwie die Fernbedienung anzuzapfen.
Oder vielleicht ist sogar ganz einfach und die Fernbedienungen sind ganz normale Infrarot-Codes, die geschickt werden.
Dann könnte man, das ist nämlich ziemlich easy, einfach mal mitschneiden und mit einem ESP und einem Infrarot-Sender nachbauen.
Yes, to pranken.
Was man da halt nicht mitbekommt ist zum Beispiel ob der Filter leer ist oder sowas, aber da könnte man das auch viel einfacher machen,
weil wenn der Filter leer ist, leuchtet ein LED rot an der Seite und da könnte ich einfach so ein Fotosensor dran machen.
Kostet ja auch noch 20 Cent so ein Ding.
Dann kriege ich es auch mit.
Kurz Kliemann nach Anmachung schon wieder zu wahren.
Ähm, keiner das hatten wir schon.
Wenn man das nicht flaschen kann ist es kein Klo.
Ich würde eher sagen, wenn man das nicht fluschen kann, also nicht flaschen kann,
dann ist es kein Klo.
Hopp, hopp.
Beste.
Was sage, äh, also bisher ist bei allem, nicht nur bei Grills, bei allen ist das Klo super angekommen.
Das hat ja sogar eine extra Girl-Funktion das Klo.
Wie heißt, eine Lady-Dusche-Funktion.
Sind extra drinnen, hat sogar ein extra Knopf dafür.
Habt ihr doch gerade auf der Fernbedienung gesehen.
Ein extra Knopf.
Wenn du bei der Arbeit aufs Klo musst, gehst du dann zuerst nach Hause.
Ich versuche tatsächlich, sofern es möglich ist, nur daheim aufs Klo zu gehen, seit ich da mein Highend-Klo habe.
Jaja.
Ey, in der Bahn, nie.
Da habe ich lieber Bauchkrämpfe, wenn ich so dringend kacken muss, bevor ich in der Bahn kacken gehe.
Das war klar, dass dies Thema gefällt, Twitch chat natürlich wieder richtig gut, ne.
Bahnflame, mein letztes Video auf dem Channel ist doch Bahnflame.
Ne, mein letztes Video auf dem Channel ist Nvidiaflame.
Ja, kenne ich.
Das ist ein JavaScript-Terminal.
Hast du auch ein smartes Licht?
Äh, da hatten wir es vorhin schon mal.
Ja, ich habe eins, was RGB kann.
Da lasse ich mir anzeigen, wie viel Verspätung der Zug hat morgens.
Aber ansonsten bin ich kein Fan von smarter Beleuchtungen, was An- und Ausschalten angeht, weil man kann es einfach mit dem Lichtschalter ausschalten.
Ich finde es viel besser, wenn man den Lichtschalter, wenn man da einen Relay einbaut.
Was natürlich ganz cool ist, wenn man RGB-Steuerung haben möchte oder irgendwelche RGB-Beleuchtungen passend zur Stimmung machen will oder sowas.
Ja, dann ist es ganz nett.
Wobei, dann würde ich das mit LED-Leisten machen.
Hab ich nicht.
RGB-Beleuchtung ist bei mir in der Heimautomatisierung noch ziemlich unterrepräsentiert.
Bisschen unter...
Ja, da kommt noch ein bisschen was in Zukunft wahrscheinlich.
Also was ich gerne hätte, ist zum Beispiel ein Schlafzimmer, eine LED-Leiste.
Dass man da morgens ein anderes Licht machen kann, wie abends zum Einschlafen.
Oder eben auch, wenn man einfach mal da Licht auf dem Tablet irgendwie mal ein bisschen was anguckt, das passende Licht.
Das würde ich gerne machen, aber das ist bei mir auf der Prioritätsmodus ganz unten.
Zwar das Licht hatten wir.
Benutzte den Mann- und den Frau-Modus zur Gang.
Das Klo ist standardmäßig genderneutral.
Also voll auf der Höhe der Zeit.
Hast du Stromausfall, dann ist das Klo nicht verspült.
Die Spülung, die ist analog.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Wasserkasten, wo du drauf drückst und dann kommt die Spülung raus.
Das Spülen für den Bobbes, für den Hintern, das geht natürlich ohne Strom nicht.
IP liegt, oh fuck.
Oh fuck, IP liegt, Leute.
MonkaS.
MonkaShake, MonkaSmoke, Alter.
Ja, das gefällt Richard, Schatz.
Video, wo ich die Klos geflammt hab, ja.
Ich hab mal die Bahn geflammt, weil es in Hanau keinen ordentlichen Klo gab.
Das war schlimm.
Fernbedienung ist noch nie ins Klo gefallen.
Tablet hab ich öfters mal im Bad.
Was haben wir eigentlich für Themen, Alter?
Was ist hier los?
Ich erzähl jetzt seit 20 Minuten schon über wie ich auf meinen Klo kacken gehe
und es gucken 150 Leute zu.
Was ist denn hier eigentlich wieder verkehrt?
Was ist hier wieder verkehrt?
Genau, das Klo was bootet.
Naja, du kannst beim, wenn du auf das Frauen-Icon drückst, hast du einen Lady-Dusche-Modus.
Kannst du dann quasi nicht nur hinten, sondern auch vorne spülen lassen.
Was ist der Sinn des Lebens?
Das zu machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Soviel mir geht.
Was hältst du von X, dein Endsmartphone, nichts mitgemacht?
Hatte dein Klo schon mal einen Plus-Screen?
Das hatte zwar noch keinen Plus-Screen, aber das hat sich mal aufgehängt nach einem Filterwechsel.
Dann gingen keine Knöpfe mehr.
Aber der Luftfilter.
Aber Reboot hat geregelt, dann ging es wieder.
Klo-Papierfalte oder Knöll?
Knöll.
Ich verstehe Leute nicht, die Klo-Papier falten.
Das muss richtig raw werden.
Review vom Klo habe ich schon, habe ich schon, gibt es bei mir auf YouTube?
Hier, Klo-Review.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels hier.
Auf YouTube 100.000 Aufrufe.
Klo-Review, da war es noch ganz neu.
Damals habe ich noch nicht mal gecheckt, dass man die Ferne, die unten noch ausziehen kann.
Ja.
Wie kann ich in PAP MQTT steuern?
Am besten wahrscheinlich über einen Shell-Befehl.
Es gibt 100 pro 1000 pro eine MQTT PAP Library.
Garantiert.
Das finde ich cool.
Serious Max, das finde ich cool.
Monka Smoke, wenn irgendwelche China-Dinger abbrennen.
Was heißt hier von dem wie Mord?
Oder den hier?
Das finde ich richtig gut.
Weiche ich mir mal.
Das finde ich auch nice.
Das dritte gefällt mir auch am besten.
Also mir gefällt das dritte am besten.
Die Frage ist, wie das aussieht, wenn es klein ist.
Das schreiben wir auf, das machen wir.
Bis ich Partner bin, bis ich Partner bin,
müssen wir uns da leider mit einem Bella-Twitch-TV-E-Mode begnügen.
Ja, aber Serious Max, das ist cool.
MQTT-Library.
CE-Aufkleber mitbestellen für China-Geräte, beste.
Gibt es schon ein eigenes Tool für Abstimmung?
Nein, gibt es noch nicht.
Da nehmen wir einfach Straw-Pool für.
Welche Bar benutzt du mit I3?
Das Ding nennt sich I3-Status-Rust.
Das da, das verwende ich.
So, übrigens Leute, ich habe euch gesagt, 22 Uhr ist Schluss.
Ich muss pennen und arbeiten gehen morgen und überhaupt.
Gucken wir mal.
Wir haben alles abge...
Oh fuck.
Ich habe die VM ausgemacht.
Jetzt läuft natürlich auch das Pepega-Board nicht mehr.
Ja, ich weiß ja, heute ist outdated.
Okay Leute, ich muss ins Bett, sonst wäre ich noch länger aufgeblieben.
Wir machen den Schluss an der Stelle.
Original ist beste.
Also, macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Streben.
Tschüss.
Oh!
Oh mein Gott!
Fucking Gott!
Oh!
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.